Swap.
You threw me off the groove.
I was like, you're not supposed to talk back.
I'm here too!
Hello guys.
Okay, so you guys might see like this little... sorry, I looped the intro because Min and I were sharing secrets.
We were sharing secrets.
You're not invited.
They're really good secrets.
Yeah, if only you could have heard what we said.
You would never ever.
You'll never know.
You're gonna miss the FOMO.
Wait, no, didn't they want the FOMO?
You have FOMO.
Oh, you have FOMO.
What could we have said?
Oh my god.
Within like five minutes.
I'm gonna tell them right now.
Because it's about you, so it's your secret.
Wait, don't you tell me stuff too?
But the later half was your secret.
Oh yeah, first half was Doki's secrets and then later was my secrets.
Yeah, so there's two secrets that you don't know.
Two whole secrets.
Oh my god.
Two whole secrets that you were not there for.
How long are we gonna drag on this video?
We gotta give them all the FOMO.
Now that we're in these, we don't have to deal with FOMO anymore.
So we give you FOMO instead.
We give you FOMO.
We can do whatever we want.
Yeah.
Okay, so if you guys don't see the bottom right text on my end, I don't know if you're showing it, Mint.
Oh, I can move myself.
But it says, warning, this version may cause the game to crash.
So it's not our PC.
It might be a Kuso game.
I don't know.
Yeah, it might be.
It might be a Kuso game.
It says, your decision.
Yeah, I suggested the game.
Okay, so, um, so this game, I told Mint that she has to start a new game herself as well.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
So like, cause I, cause there's an intro to the game.
So don't click multiplayer, right?
Click new game?
Yeah, don't click, just do new game, and then you do normal, and then you'll be met with like an intro.
Anyway, so those who don't know what Hospital 666 is, it's basically like that, uh, was it Platform 8?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Subway?
So it's basically Platform 8.
But, or Exit 8.
Sorry, Exit 8.
It's basically Exit 8, but what if we added multiplayer in there?
How do you even do that?
I don't even know.
We're gonna find out now.
I wonder if it's like 666 floors.
There's 666 floors.
How long is this?
How long?
We're gonna be playing up until Doki's new model, you guys.
Yeah, yeah.
Into the new skin suit.
Yeah, this is 24 hours.
24 hours, by the way.
Surprise!
You know like the spookies, the jump scare mansion?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're gonna make it to floor a thousand, guys!
Is that actually how long that game is?
No way.
Oh, yeah, the spookies.
Have you ever played the jump scare one?
No, no.
Oh, yeah, I think it is.
I think it's like, uh, I think it is.
I played it before.
It's up to like a thousand floors.
What the hell?
Cause like every hundred you get, it's like a new like a new theme to the to the like rooms and stuff.
So it gets spookier and spookier.
Okay.
Um, and at one point one of them was like, uh, at one point you go to a floor that's just a fucking maze.
Someone said a thousand floors plus bonus DLC floors.
They made more floors?
No, it's, oh wait, yeah, they made more floors.
Yeah, there's DLC floors too.
And there's like, and then like you get taken to like a hospital too.
It's like spookies and hospital.
Oh, yeah, and then I also while we were like waiting for the stream, um, I linked Mint a really good
I linked Mint a Vtuber background and I was like oh my god, it's perfect.
It's so, it's the best It's actually, I should have used it today, man.
Honestly, you should have.
No, that's what they want!
That's what the Wisp want!
That background?
Yeah, yeah, okay, I'll, I'm gonna link it to my chat.
We
I'll link it to my chat too.
And then you being like you can recreate that Dr. Horrible seal Bro, everybody loves it!
Helping that random girl you see at the laundromat roleplay.
It's like, it's like the, one of the top five cliches out there.
Top five dreams.
It's true.
We could be that girl.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
There's this, there's this ghost maid in my laundromat.
My laundromat's haunted!
Oh, spooky!
Because it was like, who wants this?
I was like, what do you mean, who wants this?
No, no, no, I said, what led to them creating?
Like, what was the demand?
Like, who said, man, I really need like a laundromat?
Like, right now.
He saw a random girl at the laundromat.
He's like, well, that could be if only VTubers had this too.
Not enough anime start with a guy meeting a girl at the laundromat.
I'm telling you.
He's like, no, he's like, you know, like, the west version of weeaboos?
The west-a-boo?
Yeah, the west-a-boos!
I bet you the person who created it is a west-a-boo because they saw too many like, American TV shows where it starts off the laundromat.
He's a west-a-boo!
He wishes Japan has more of this!
I'm gonna throw chat in the laundry machine.
I'm gonna throw you guys in.
The perfect RP.
I would make it so that the chat is like, the laundromat's like, overlaid on top of chat and then you guys are spinning it.
That's too much work for me.
I won't be doing it.
Okay, I'll do it, guys.
Yeah, yeah, check Minthe channels out if you want to live your laundromat fantasies.
Wow!
See, that's why I linked you the background.
I knew you'd You knew it was made for me!
I knew it was made for you!
This background's made for you!
Okay, guys, how's our volume, by the way?
Yeah.
After all that.
I'm gonna start a new game.
Yeah, we're gonna start a new game, too.
You guys gotta see the intro.
Do I just do any difficulty?
Yeah, any difficulty and then we'll hook.
Or do normal, yeah.
Okay, I'm starting the game.
Go some balls!
Wait, is this...
This is not game footage, this is a real footage.
Yeah, this is the dev.
What is going on?
Go some balls!
Oh my god, he's so mad.
And now, we're in the game!
That was it?
Yeah, that was it.
That's what I wanted you to see.
I was like, what the fuck is this?
Now you're in the game, too.
Oh my god.
All these instructions.
They have, like, the entire world.
Wait, is he a VTuber?
Yeah, yeah, he's apparently, like, um...
Guys, by the way, guys, this developer is single.
So, ladies and guys, too.
Wait, should I turn VSync on or off?
I can't remember.
Bro, I don't know.
Okay.
She asked me if she should play on DX11 or Go, and she was like, what's the difference?
And I was like, I don't know.
Well, turning it on helped me not lag, so...
Okay, that's good.
Okay, I'm returning to the menu.
Alright, also, sound guy, turn mint up a bit more.
Is it better now?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah.
Alright, let me, I'll invite you.
Let me go to the multiplayer.
Okay.
Host, cause I don't know, did you start it off on easy?
No, I did normal.
Okay.
I couldn't tell.
Cause you were like, oops.
And I was like, oh no, what do you mean, oops?
Alright.
How do I invite you?
Can you give me a sec?
Oh, the friends list is like, empty for me.
Oh, okay.
So... This is fine.
That should be fine, right?
Alright.
I can invite you to watch this game.
Wait, can you go to multiplayer and see if you find me in the game?
No, you're not there.
I'm not there?
Okay.
I have no friends.
Oh, okay.
No, I meant like, you know how you go to multiplayer?
Do I show up on multiplayer?
No.
I don't?
Okay, this is awkward.
What if I press host?
Oh.
Well, if you're hosting then I can join you.
Yeah, try me, try me.
Okay, give me a sound.
Alright, return to menu.
Refresh, refresh.
Why don't you exist on my friends list?
See, that's what I'm saying!
Wait, can you invite me?
Uh...
You guys, we're not professionals, okay?
We're indie vtubers, please.
You have to have zero expectations on us.
We're indie vtubers, please understand.
Please understand.
It is just us right now.
We're not professionals.
We should not be put up to standards when it comes to corporate vtubers.
We're just one person.
I say when I have a team bond.
Well, I don't.
So I can actually, it's just me, myself, and I.
How do I invite friends?
Okay, hold on.
I can invite to watch.
I can watch you.
How do I invite you?
I boosted her volume again.
Sound guy.
How do I join you?
Uh oh.
Guys, give us a sec.
Instead of, you know, we met up 15 minutes before the stream started and instead of preparing the stream, we were sharing secrets.
We were sharing secrets.
Oh my god.
We had our priorities.
It was a juicy good secret.
If you knew the secret, you would have been like, good choice.
You know?
Okay, I'm gonna do friends.
I'm gonna change my profile settings and see if you can invite me now.
Okay.
You see me on, I think you see me on VTube Studios instead of Hospital.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna return to the menu.
Yeah.
I'm gonna multiplayer.
I'm gonna, I'll host.
I'm gonna host a game.
I don't think if you host it, you show up, right?
And then, um, no, it should be.
Cause like, what's the point of hosting it if you don't like, what's the point of hosting it?
How did the other people No, there's no way other VTubers were able to test this out.
That's true.
We can't be as, we can't be stupider than other VTubers.
I guess we can, Dokie.
Yes, we can.
No, we can't.
There's no way.
All VTubers have like almost equivalent IQ.
Wait, how do you add or how do you invite someone on Steam?
I never know.
Wait, what?
That's what I was telling you to do.
How do I do that?
Shift tab.
Nothing showed up.
Oh, just kidding, just kidding.
Have you never done shift tab before?
No.
What do you mean you've never?
Now how do I add you?
Alright, you see where Dokie bird is, and then you go to invite.
Oh, I can invite you to watch.
But it's not even watch the game, it's watch me, Bridger.
I mean, don't you want to watch my face?
The whole time?
The whole time, definitely.
We both have like a solo session of Hospital 666.
And we're just watching.
Like we sync up our Hospital 666 gameplay together.
Obviously.
Or like see who gets to the most floors.
We can make it a competition.
Oooooh.
I'm gonna start my game.
Maybe it's not us.
Guys, maybe it's not us.
We need to play in DX mode.
Oh, did we actually have to play in DX mode?
I don't know.
Oh, I got an achievement for leaving the game.
Oh, okay.
Okay, guys.
We got this.
We can do this, guys.
We can have chat.
No, it's good chat.
You guys get more content.
We could have ended earlier if we didn't have this.
I'm ending the stream right now.
Okay, I'm hosting again.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, are you on DX11?
I'm on DX11, yeah.
Okay, I'm on the normal one.
So I don't know if that affects anything.
Okay, can you see mine?
I see you!
Oh my god, it was DX11 all along!
I'm joining.
Hopefully it doesn't crash because it said that this version...
I'm in the floor.
You're on the floor?
I don't see you.
No, I'm in the floor.
Wait, you're in the floor?
Where are you?
I hear noises.
I hear you.
I see you walking on top of you.
I think I hear you walking.
Wait, go towards the man with the hat.
Can I see you?
Go towards the man with the hat.
Okay, can you see me?
I'm stuck in the floor.
I'm gonna leave you.
Go to the next floor!
Yeah, go to the next floor.
Wait, remember I said layout.
This is what it looks like.
Figure it out!
This is a default!
Figure it out then!
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna leave you.
Goodbye.
I see the doors closing.
Where are you?
I'm still stuck in the floor.
Are you on the next story?
I'm on the next story.
Did you come back?
I'm going up another floor.
I'm gonna go back up another floor.
Are you still on the first floor?
I can't even exit to the menu.
Pressing escape does nothing.
I'm still on the second floor.
Okay, I'm leaving the game.
I'm gonna start a new game.
Okay.
Okay, I'll join you.
I'll join you.
Maybe that'll work.
Okay, okay.
I'm not doing the DX.
I'm joining normal.
Okay, I'm hosting.
Okay.
Sound guy, I turned down mint a little bit.
Is it better now?
We're still adjusting sound while figuring out how to play this game.
It's okay.
We're in these guys.
We're in these.
Okay, can you see me in the game?
Okay.
No.
I don't see you in the game.
No, I do not.
Wait, how did you see me?
Maybe it was the DX mode.
I'm telling you, man.
I'll go on DX mode.
We'll swap.
We'll just try hosting again.
Okay, I'll do DX mode.
This is so great, you guys.
Guys, we are professionals here.
This is all because we didn't even test it.
You have to see the new game intro.
That is not true.
We didn't test it because I showed her the laundromat.
Get it right.
Sorry, my bad.
You're right.
There's a sequence of events that led to this.
Are you in the game yet?
I'm in the game, yeah.
Okay, because I don't see you.
Maybe it's because you're...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I'm hosting.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I also have another idea.
I think it's because your Steam is on...
You don't show what game you're playing on Steam.
Because I've made mine friends only.
So you should make yours friends only.
And then after the stream, we private it.
How do you do that?
What do you mean?
That's...
Okay.
You know...
What did you learn in the last three years?
What do you mean?
Okay.
Go to...
Go to Steam.
Click your name.
Go to privacy settings.
Hold on.
Where is...
Click...
Wait.
Under my profile?
Okay.
You go to...
Yeah.
Go to...
Tokyo.
Go to Tokyo.
Go to edit profile.
Okay.
Oh, privacy settings.
Yeah.
And then friends only.
Oh, my God.
No way that actually fixed it.
No way.
Oh, my God.
I can see you now.
Come on.
Join the game.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, my God.
It was the Steam thing all over again.
I can't believe you learned this as an indie.
I'm just getting my feet off the ground.
I've been around for two months.
Come on.
Give me a break.
You...
You can't say that.
You existed five years ago.
When I existed, you existed.
When we were both indies.
You can't say that.
Okay.
You know what, Doki?
You need to shave.
Okay?
Come on.
Get out of my way.
I'm ready to get out of this hospital.
Oh, my God.
Did you hear that?
Can we open the door?
How do you open the door?
I don't think we can.
Okay.
I don't think we're allowed to.
Oh, wait.
That's us.
That's our Triplet.
We're visiting a Triplet at the hospital.
Solid Liquid Solid.
Alright.
We've got to memorize this layout.
We've got to figure out what the anomalies are later.
Okay.
Look at that.
Wait.
I heard that there's a thing I can do in multiplayer.
Can I do it?
Oh, I...
Yeah.
That's where you want to get beat up, in the hospital.
Don't make me press the button!
I'm in here, I'm in here too!
Slamming the button.
I'm gonna punch you in the balls, that's what I'm gonna do.
No, I'm gonna punch you first!
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
Are you gonna make it to the elevator?
First one there is running!
Oh yeah, push me back to the elevator!
Come on!
I'm gonna make it before you!
No!
Give me it!
Wait, wait, wait.
No, I can't!
You can't punch me from the elevator!
Yes you can!
I'm punching your...
I like how we are not checking the anomalies.
We're back to floor zero.
Wait, what do you mean we're back to floor zero?
What happened?
Look at the elevator!
What do you mean what happened?
What do you mean?
But we're advancing!
Look at the elevator!
Oh dude, I have to play the game!
Oh!
Boo boo.
Dammit, I can't leave you.
I haven't been to the floor.
All right.
I don't think there's any anomalies.
Wait, are you getting coffee?
Yeah.
Not for you.
Why get coffee when we can get GamerSubs?
I saw it.
Anyway guys, did you guys know that we both have GamerSubs codes?
We both have codes!
Yeah!
Anyway, feel free to use a Doughkeeper.
We both have codes!
Or Boomer, which is the cooler, more trendy code to use.
Or the link in the description.
Link in the description.
There's no link in your description.
Yes, there is!
I'm getting to the elevator first!
Wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
What?
Oh, we were... Wait, you are!
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Wait, I think there's a nominee here.
You think so?
Yeah, I think so.
What is it?
I don't think there is two cats.
You can't even press the button!
You can't even go!
No!
I can't do it!
What's the point?
We have to find the anomaly.
Come on.
I don't know.
Everything looks the same.
Wait, isn't he on the other side?
He's backwards.
No, he was always here.
No, because like...
This is where we start off.
Because this is where you got coffee, remember?
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
Yeah, and then you're like...
Go over here and you're like...
There's all the medicine.
There's this beautiful vista.
Alright, let me read the rules.
You find anomaly, press the L button.
Let me read the rules.
It's 30 minutes into this stream.
We played this game for 5 minutes.
20 minutes of this game with text support.
Okay, if you don't find the anomaly, press the button from the another elevator.
Oh, from the elevator over on this side.
So if we don't find the anomaly, we just gotta...
Oh, we come back here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can use the top button to review the previous floor.
Orange light outside means you're starting from this elevator.
Oh, okay, so it tells you like which elevator you start from.
Wait, no, if you don't find an anomaly, press the button from another...
Oh, so if we find an anomaly, we come here.
If we don't find an anomaly, we go over there.
It's wherever, it's whatever elevator you start with.
Yeah.
Because both elevators have the same instruction.
So if we find an anomaly, we go up a floor.
I don't think you're, like, or like...
We go, if we find one, we go here.
If we don't find one, we go down there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, we press the, yeah, yeah.
No, it's because there's a restart.
There's a...
No, that's if you want to go back to the previous floor.
Oh!
Guys, see, we can lean.
Okay, do you think there's an anomaly?
No, I think so, I think we're good.
Okay, hold on, there's five, six doors.
Two, four, six.
Okay, one, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay.
That's what I said.
I don't know, I'm worried you couldn't count, you know.
Okay.
Because we're VTubers.
They care about our health.
Yeah, there's, like, lots of meds here.
Guys, remember to take your meds.
That's all of Doki's meds right there.
Yeah, and that...
Yeah, yeah, Mitt's meds is in this room.
It's an entire room dedicated to her meds.
Okay, okay.
This one is so that she can count.
This one's so she can read.
This one is...
Wait, I can't beat you up anymore.
This one's so that my imaginary...
What happened?
Oh, no, I need to take my meds.
I've lost control of my arms.
This one is so my imaginary friend will finally disappear.
But I didn't take it.
That's why it's all here.
Why can't I punch you?
All right, let's just go up and see what happens.
Because I didn't take my meds.
All right.
We go...
We go up.
I think we're...
I think we're good.
What's that?
All right, we'll see.
It's gonna go to two.
It's gonna go to two?
Yeah.
It's not moving.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, it's back to zero.
I knew we fucked it up.
There's no...
It was...
What did we mess up?
Okay.
Wait.
So this is zero.
So we can figure out what is all...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So water.
Exit side.
The meds are still here.
Water.
Yeah.
All right.
There's two trash cans.
There's two fires.
Did you count the six doors?
Did you count...
Yes, I counted the six doors.
I just wanted to be sure.
Okay.
It's cast.
So, cafe cappuccino.
Waterfalls.
Cafe con...
What's it called?
Panal.
All right.
I think we can go up the floor.
Okay.
I think this is what...
Maybe the side.
I think this is what patient zero looks like.
Yeah.
Maybe the side.
One.
We can pay attention.
We are...
There's two of us.
Like, this is a...
Yeah.
...mount of, like, five people.
There's two of us.
This is a...
This is a one to four player game, okay?
It's not our fault we're missing two players to help us.
Was this always here?
Yeah.
This was always here.
Okay.
I've seen this before.
And there was always, like, two...
I don't trust her.
Okay.
All right.
Then, let's stay on this elevator.
Let's stay over here and press the button if you don't trust me.
I mean, the guys...
Oh!
Oh, my God!
There's an anomaly!
What's the anomaly?
This guy is running.
What?
Oh, my God!
Are you sure?
Wait, what do you mean am I sure?
Do you not see it?
No.
He's standing still.
Wait, actually?
Yeah.
Are you sure?
Are you gaslighting me?
I have photographic proof.
I'm glad I'm streaming this.
A photo means that it's a photo.
It's a photo!
It's a snapshot!
A photo isn't animated.
That proves my point.
No, chat.
I took my...
You guys, come on.
Believe me.
Come on.
Look at him.
He's running!
No, mince chat.
It's not running, right?
Mince chat.
It is running, right?
It's not.
I don't see it.
I'm pretty sure...
I'm looking at stream right now.
It's not running.
Yes, yes!
You see it!
Use your eyes!
You forgot to take the meds...
to use your eyes.
I can only see it five frames per second.
Wait, so then that means...
we go back to this one, right?
Yeah, we go back and we go up.
Yeah, okay.
You know how...
some video cameras...
can only see certain frames?
And then...
you can actually have a video of a bird...
whose wings are just like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Those are my eyes.
Okay.
I think you need to get help for that.
Oh, we're at two!
That was me.
We did not do anything.
I did it!
We did it together.
This is a team game.
It's a collab.
What you accomplish...
is what I can accomplish.
Oh my god.
And now he's green.
He's not running at all.
Alright.
I am looking at the calendar.
Medical center first.
Everything looks the same.
Yeah.
You know what?
I think you know who...
Wait!
There's three clocks!
Wait, wasn't there always three clocks?
I only saw one before.
Maybe that was the anomaly.
Wait, maybe...
Oh, I think it is three clocks is the anomaly.
So we go up from here.
See, we're doing so good!
Teamwork!
We're doing so good, guys!
I think, you know what?
You know who can be our third and fourth player?
Chat.
Yeah, how true!
See!
Yeah!
One clock!
Oh my god.
I think we're really good at this game.
This game is too easy.
It's not like we fucked up like three times...
before we figured it out.
The royal we.
Yeah, sure.
I don't think there's any anomalies this time.
It doesn't look like it.
Well, you said that last time and there were three clocks!
Look, I didn't look behind me!
How many doors?
Doki, how many doors are there?
Six.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
See, I can count too.
She took her meds, everybody.
Yeah, I took my meds.
You see?
Up we go!
I can't go up a floor without you, man!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Don't go back to zero.
Wait, does it go back to zero if we lose?
Yeah, it goes back to zero if we lose.
I don't even know how many floors it's supposed to be.
Okay, we're at four!
We're doing it!
Alright.
Everything looks fine.
Okay, there's two fire hydrants.
Wait, wait, wait!
The fire hydrants!
There's always been two.
Yeah, but then look at the labels.
Weren't they like, together?
Like, the same label?
Oh, I don't know.
But also, wait, we started on the other side.
Is that normal?
No, we went here.
We came to this elevator because there was no anomaly.
So we started on that side.
Okay, okay, okay.
You're right, you're right.
Check the meds.
How many doors?
I said fire hydrants and you agreed with me.
Oh, fire extinguishers.
I'm in the...
I told you, chat!
There's, there's, there's, there's!
Oh, the water!
It's leaking.
Oh my god!
What's going on here?
Wait, okay, that's water.
Why is there blood here?
Why is there blood also here?
And it's old blood, too, because it's dark red.
Ooh.
Somebody, like, stubbed her toe or something.
I think that is a pretty extreme stubbed toe.
I think...
So, we go in this one, right?
No, we go on the other...
No, we go on the other one.
There's an anomaly.
I'm confused!
I don't remember how we did this.
Oh my god, the VTuber is up here now.
And you find the elevator.
Anomaly, press the button from the elevator you come from.
Yeah, from the elevator you come from.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
See?
We're doing it.
I told you this is a team of we.
We.
We, we.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Fifth floor.
Chat, how many floors is this?
They don't know.
They probably don't know.
They've seen gameplay of this before.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Fire extinguisher.
That looks fine.
Everything looks fine.
The medicine looks the same.
Did you see that?
What was that?
Shit!
Get away!
Yeah, I think this floor was cursed.
I think this floor was cursed.
I think this floor is cursed.
What did you see?
Did you see the skeleton?
The face?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I looked at the painting.
I looked at this painting.
There was a face in the painting and I looked at it.
And I was like, what's this?
It showed up on my whole screen.
I told you.
This is a Wii team.
What I do, you get affected.
Why is this guy just sitting here the whole time?
Why is he here?
He's like triplet.
He's moral support.
He needs to be a team player.
He's the one that popped out like five minutes later.
So we don't talk about him.
He was in there a little too long.
He's like super cooked in the oven.
It's fine.
He's just the silent archetype.
Oh, we're like the Huey, Dewey, and Louie.
I think we're more like the three stooges.
I think it's good.
I think so too.
So we should be at the other side then.
Of the elevator.
We should be on this side.
Because if there's no anomaly, we go to the other side.
How are you still wondering about the elevator?
The rules.
I can't remember this.
We're on the sixth floor.
I'm just finding anomalies, okay?
Wait, no.
Oh yeah, if you find it, go back to the elevator.
Oh my god, I can't do this.
There are two rules.
It's too complicated.
What do you mean there's two rules?
It can't be complicated with these two rules.
I thought you had...
photographic memory.
I didn't say I had photographic memory.
I didn't say that even once.
Wait, what did you say?
You had photographic something.
I don't remember.
Well, we know you definitely don't have photographic memory.
No, definitely not.
I don't see any anomalies.
I don't see anything either.
Let's see.
One, two, three, four...
Count the doors!
I counted, there's six.
Okay, and the fire extinguishers are real.
They look good.
Oh wait!
There's a six on this door.
Wasn't there a six?
Was there always a six?
There's a six on every door.
Was that always the case?
I think so.
I can't remember.
Chat, do your part.
Come on.
You're the game.
You're player three and four.
Why are they all labeled six?
What's the point of streaming if you don't help out?
No help.
What are you talking about?
Chat, is this real?
I think it's an anomaly.
Guys, is this...
Has this always been here?
Chat...
Guys, is there anything on the floor?
No help.
Why do they keep saying that?
Guys, you're...
Guys, our fucking live tag...
is literally called Bird Cedars.
As in Back Cedars.
Where are my goddamn Back Cedars?
Okay, Back Cedars, it's your time to rise.
Yes, your time to shine.
You guys love telling the streamer what to do.
Guys...
Tell the streamer what to do.
They said it's an anomaly.
Wait, which one did we come from?
Which elevator?
No help?
Wait, you're right.
Oh no, this one.
This one.
The orange.
Whatever has the orange...
Where does it say...
What do you mean whatever has the orange?
Whatever has the orange is where we came from.
What orange are you talking about?
This.
The orange...
Look up.
Oh, like the orange lighting.
Oh my god.
Did you just say the orange?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Literally, because it's orange.
What do you want me to say?
I said orange...
The orange lighting.
What do you mean?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Maybe you were in the womb too long.
Hey, I'm not like him.
And he's a good guy, okay?
How would you know?
He doesn't even talk to us.
How do you know that?
So we come here.
I think it's an anomaly.
I don't remember seeing the sixes before.
I'm pretty sure the sixes have always been here.
Right?
Chat.
If you don't help us, we're going back to floor zero.
Do you want that?
Do you want to see us back to floor zero?
The orange.
What does no help mean?
They said yes.
It means no help.
I don't know.
I'm just thinking maybe there's something in it that says no help.
They're just being stupid.
No, don't call them stupid now.
They'll definitely won't help.
They like it.
They like it a little bit.
Okay, we're taking the risk.
Okay, all right.
Oh wait, we could have gone to the previous floor.
Oh shit, you're right.
We could have gone to the...
All right, here we go.
Wait, I'm looking though.
Yeah, it was an anomaly.
I dare you to go in.
I dare you.
Wait, there was an anomaly then.
Yeah, it wasn't an anomaly.
It was the six on the doors.
The one that I caught.
Oh!
Yeah, all me.
No, I already dared you first.
I double dare you.
By the rules, I double dare you.
I triple dog dare you.
Bye.
All right, goodbye.
Goodbye, Mint.
Wait, I get affected too?
Okay, this is a team game.
Don't ever triple dog dare me to do anything ever again.
You mean I can't move on from her death?
That's not fair, Debs.
Debs, that is not fair.
She can hold us hostage.
That is not fair.
All F4s out of the game.
That's what he does.
Okay, do you want to host it?
All right.
We know.
Let's see if you host it, continue the game, and see if we go back to the eighth floor.
Continue.
Does it do it?
Oh wait, wait, I just pressed continue.
I didn't press host.
Oh, I'm on floor eight!
Yeah, I told you.
Come here, come here, come here, wait, yeah, come here, come here, come here.
I think I... Okay, let me see how I can...
Come on, come on.
I'm figuring this out!
Get in here, get in here.
Okay, I can watch your game.
Wait, you didn't click host!
You're in a single player game!
You have to go back to the main menu.
I just press continue.
Yeah, yeah, oh wait, oh I see you, I see you.
Hold on, hold on, let me see.
Okay, okay, I'm in, I'm in.
We're at level eight!
Yeah!
Yippee!
Okay, no.
Yeah, yeah, no.
We're not doing that again, yeah, yeah.
We got...
We got achievement where like, I think the game crashed.
I think so.
That was the achievement.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh yeah, there was no sixes!
Yeah!
Alright!
Little friend.
Our brother.
Alright.
Our triplet.
Our Louie.
Louie was the silent one, right?
I have no idea.
I don't know, I don't remember.
Aren't those the ducks?
Yeah, they're the...
Yes, it's the ducks.
But none of them were silent, right?
Yeah, no, one of them was like the newer DuckTales.
The newer DuckTales.
Oh.
One of them was like, they made one of them silent.
And then one of them was the Sonic's voice actor.
Oh yeah, I knew that.
And the other one was Abed.
Abed, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I think we're good here.
I think so too.
I think there's no anomalies.
I don't think so either.
Yeah.
Move.
No, you move.
We're team...
You move.
WrestleTuber 20, 20, 25.
We have Abed in Hospital 666 WrestleTuber.
The sequel to WrestleTuber, we're going to a hospital.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
10 floor.
10.
Yeah.
We're so good at this game.
We are really good at this game.
Yeah.
We can see all the anomalies.
I thought the doors would open at some point.
I think that's like, you know how there's a locked part?
I know the doors, you can open them, but I think, you know, like when you start a game, it's like easy, normal, and locked.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think the locked portion, you can open the doors.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Our vision is terrible.
We have to get...
We have to get all of you close.
What are these?
No, I can see it.
I think it's right.
Wait.
May, June, July.
That's right.
We care about your health.
Why is it like if I'm like halfway in between, it gets like really blurry?
I think you need glasses.
I can see it fine.
Are you on low quality?
Probably.
The game defaults to low graphics.
Yeah, because it's making me lag anyway sometimes.
Oh, wait.
Really?
Yeah.
I opened it up this time and DX.
Maybe it'll help.
Ah!
Stop it!
Stop going wombo-combo on your ass.
She's the violent triplet.
She's the one that mom had to take to the hospital.
I have anger issues.
Wait.
So, do we go in this one?
Yeah.
We go to this one because there's no anomalies.
Okay.
All right.
Up.
Up we go.
Eleven.
Yeah, it's my soldier jeans.
Exactly.
She has the killing gene in here.
Oh!
I think...
I don't know about...
I think you should have talked to her.
I can fix her.
Okay.
All right.
One clock.
One brother.
All the coffees.
Oh!
I think...
I think something's happening on that floor.
No.
All right.
We're fine.
See?
Everything is fine.
I'm not letting you out of here.
Oh!
Look up.
Yeah.
We are speedrunning this game.
I think...
I think this is a fire hazard.
All right.
With all those fire alarms.
See?
They're a little paranoid.
That's okay.
All right.
This looks normal.
Finally.
This looks like a normal time.
Yeah.
Everything looks good.
Okay.
So far.
All right.
Coffee.
Gold.
So good.
Our brother is still here.
Wait.
There's still...
Have there always been this many fire alarms?
I haven't been looking up.
Gamers don't look up, you guys.
Yeah.
Gamers don't look...
I think it's...
Wait.
Has there?
I don't know.
I don't think that's...
Now I'm paranoid.
Yeah.
Me too.
After seeing like 200 fire alarms on one ceiling.
Now I don't know.
Has there always been?
That's a little bit too much, isn't it?
Right.
I feel like...
But they wouldn't...
I feel like a hospital shouldn't have that many.
They wouldn't do two anomalies with this many.
Like with a bunch of fire alarms, right?
I mean, the fucking dev crashed our game, so I feel like that's something.
Wait a minute.
This door is huge.
Oh, you're right.
Wait.
The doors are huge.
Yeah.
Oh, we're tiny.
Oh.
I like how we passed like five doors in a minute.
Every single...
We went through five doors in a minute.
We went to the very end of the hallway.
We went through five doors and we're like, that seems normal.
We're regressing in our height, in our old age.
Look, we were focused on the fire alarms.
We're focused on the safety.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
The door is open.
I triple dare dog dare you to go through that door.
I did it last time.
You...
You go.
How about we do it together as twins?
No, you baby.
Baby.
As twins.
We do this together.
Why didn't you come with me last time then?
I did.
No, you didn't.
I saw you in the elevator.
I was about to get out of that elevator when you went in.
I was gonna...
Go.
Go, Doki.
Go in there.
Oh.
Go to the other one.
What do you mean?
That was...
There's more than one?
Yeah.
Another door opened.
What do you mean?
Okay, I just did that door.
It's your turn.
No, no, no.
We swap.
Go, Doki.
Whatever jump scare comes out, you get it too.
Okay, good.
There's another one.
Is this some Scooby Doo shit?
Oh.
Go get the other one.
Go.
Go, Doki.
No.
Go.
Yeah,
that's right.
Oh.
There.
I knew it's the same door.
This door opened before.
It is Scooby Doo.
It's looping.
I told you, it's Scooby Doo.
What's new Scooby-Doo?
Someone's like this instigator mint.
Oh, yeah, it is cow- I read that wrong.
Yeah, it is coward dokey instigator mint.
You're ready to like rip that chatter apart.
I was like, what do you mean coward mint?
Can we finally have a regular floor?
We've had like anomalies like back to back.
Um, it's not normal.
It's not normal.
He's happy.
Solidus.
He's like gamer subs.
Oh my god, he's laughing.
Where he is?
Is this the dev?
Is this the dev's laugh?
Oh my god, is he getting louder?
Maybe that's why he's single.
We win what's going on.
What's going on?
Oh what the heck was that bloody butt baby?
It was the scp.
Yes, oh my god.
What was that?
What is that?
What's going on?
Abrid victory
We gotta get vent to the elevator, we gotta get vent to the elevator!
What?
me me me it's marketing whyctor
Oh my god.
It's really coming after you.
Wait, I can't get past.
He's blocking the way.
I took too long.
I'm stuck.
I can't get past.
What if he turns around?
I'm gonna...
Oh, he's not turning around.
He's not turning around.
Wait, I'm not getting... You need to be in the elevator.
Oh, we escaped from the statue.
We escaped from floor 66.
Oh, we're at 100!
We're at 100!
Wait, how did we get to 100?
I don't know.
Oh, that's the door again.
It's the door again.
No!
I think... I don't think... I think this is because we've advanced now.
It's like a new... Oh, that's why... Oh, so there's more to this.
Now we have to memorize this floor.
Okay, there's aspirin.
There's a med kit.
Our brother moved.
He finally... You know, like, the American healthcare system where you have to, like, wait in the waiting room for, like, hours?
Hours and hours?
He finally got it!
Yeah!
Water.
He's next!
He just has to wait another five hours.
He just needs to... Yeah, he needs to wait another five hours.
But at least he gets a chair now.
He gets a chair?
Yeah.
Everything out here looks the same, I think.
Besides him.
I think this is, like... I think it's the default.
Like, uh... Like, oh, this is what it looks like with no anomalies.
I think.
It has to be.
I think so, yeah.
I think so.
Because, like, we started off on this floor.
Okay, let's look in here.
Okay, there's a big old couch.
There's two chairs.
Oh, yeah.
Memorize that with your non-photographic memory.
Yeah, I'm going to.
Plant.
Wheelchair.
Two chairs here.
There's two chairs everywhere.
Two chairs.
Two hospital beds.
There's a chair here.
Vitamins.
How many hospital beds?
More vitamins.
One, two, three, four, five hospital beds.
And then it's, like, blue and then purple, purple.
Yeah, yeah.
Purple.
Blue.
Alright.
Purple.
We should be good.
We're not going to remember this.
No, we're not going to remember this.
This is why chat's here.
Chat, let's just do your part.
Do your part, everybody.
Do your part.
You love Helldivers, too.
Now it's time to...
It's just like Helldivers.
Why is everybody saying, no Elf?
Why don't you...
Are your H keys broken?
What's going on?
101!
Let's go!
Yay!
Okay.
Is our brother in the hospital room?
I'm going to go check on him.
Wait.
Go check on him.
I think everything looks the same out here.
Yeah.
Let's see.
The paintings are the same.
Oh!
What?
This room is haunted!
Why?
Go check!
Go look, you baby!
Go look!
This room is haunted!
No, no!
Fuck you!
No, it's not!
Yes, it is!
How is it haunted?
It's your cousin!
What is he doing here?
You are such a baby for him!
She ghost!
It's a ghost!
I didn't know!
I didn't expect your...
I didn't expect your cousin to come to this class!
It's actually my face reveal.
Thank you very much.
You have like a fucking ghost sheet underneath.
It's underneath my skin suit.
So underneath my skin suit is a tomato.
Underneath her skin suit is a Halloween costume.
At least I don't rot.
You know that!
I could be like an alien tomato!
You're not ripe anymore!
What about the boomer code?
It's like boomer!
Get it?
Cause I say boo a lot!
Where's the mer for?
Mer!
Wait, did I just see something in there?
What do you mean?
Oh, you're showing me a baby now!
Oh, no, there's definitely something in there.
It's twitching.
Oh yeah, there's definitely... Oh yeah, I see that.
Go, go, go.
Wait, what?
I went in last time!
No, you didn't!
I don't want to talk about it.
Yes, I did.
Chat would agree with me.
What is that?
We're going together!
As twins, we go in together.
Okay, you go first.
We can't go... Okay.
You go first, I'll go in after.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Oh, it's a body bag.
Oh, it's like crunchy.
It is?
Yeah.
Oh, why is it crunchy?
Why is it crunchy?
Yeah.
Is he eating cereal in there?
Are we playing the Mortary Assistant again?
Oh God, please don't!
I'd rather die again than play that game.
Wait, so how many floors did we get to before we got to the 66?
I don't remember, honestly.
I don't remember.
We were...
We definitely didn't do 100 floors, I think.
Yeah.
Oh!
Wait, what?
Did you hear that?
Oh!
Whoa!
Wait, another door opened.
Oh, okay.
Okay, it's time to go.
It's time to go.
Yeah, it's time to go.
Get out of here.
Yeah.
If there's no one on the wheelchair, it's either a miracle or something happened.
So what?
You mean a miracle?
Wouldn't it be more of a miracle if they get out of the wheelchair?
Not if the wheelchair goes away.
Yeah, but that means somebody just suddenly learned how to walk.
And then they push the wheelchair away.
And be like, I can walk now.
Yay!
I don't need it.
I don't need this.
I don't need it anymore.
He throws it across the room.
Okay, I think we're safe in this room now.
Wait.
Was he always staring at us?
Or...
Yeah, he was always staring at us.
That's our brother.
No, no, no, no.
No, no.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, what is so...
He's getting sentience, Dokie.
He's getting sentience.
Why should we have a normal...
He's being... He's just being wacky.
He's quirky.
Oh, Dewey.
Dewey?
I thought it was Huey.
I remember.
They all like... The names all blur together.
They truly do.
Stop punching me.
I'm sorry.
What?
You're being too slow.
I'll give you a head start.
I can't punch you anymore, I think.
You've reached your punch limit.
My punch quota.
Yeah.
The punch quota of the day.
Another one?
The anomaly.
What's up with all these anomalies?
We're speed running.
Oh, my God.
Put us on speedrun.com.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We're at one hour.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're so fast.
Oh, you got your punch quota back.
I got my punch back.
Every floor, you're getting your quota back.
I'm so sorry.
Is this a normal room?
Did we get a normal room this time?
Let's see.
Don't look at any weird faces in the pictures.
There's no weird faces in the pictures?
If I look at a weird face, you look at a weird face.
No!
I think this is a normal room.
I think so too?
I think we got a normal room for once.
The shadows are so weird.
Oh yeah, that's true.
My shadow is going over there.
Has this always been like 00100?
Okay, you can barely remember.
I looked at it earlier!
Alright, aspirin.
I think this is normal.
Oh my god.
It would be fucked up if it goes back to zero.
No, there has to be like a checkpoint.
Yeah.
Yeah, 100 must be like our checkpoint.
I think we did.
Right?
I'm scared.
We must have done it.
Okay!
Okay, nice, 107.
Oh my god.
We finally got to see the other side.
I know, right?
After so long, we've been like...
We've been stuck in there for the longest time.
Oh, anomaly!
What?
What did you see?
What was it?
He chased after me, Doki!
What?
He got up, he moved, he didn't need the wheelchair anymore.
There was no one there.
He ran!
He was running!
I think he didn't take your meds.
He ran at me!
Oh, that was Doki!
What do you mean?
Oh, wait, I mean...
What?
What happened?
He saw...
What
did you see?
What happened?
Okay, but there was an anomaly.
It was the wheelchair.
The wheelchair was shaking.
But then...
And then I thought he got up and ran at me.
But it was he.
What?
I think we were in the hospital for a human.
He saw me!
And was like...
He's chasing me!
Oh, wait.
There's bodies in here!
You bitch!
Don't you want to see the bodies move?
I already saw...
Let me rest.
109!
Give it up for 109!
Someone in the chat was like, I know Doki can be something, but calling her an anomaly.
SCP tomato.
Oh my god.
Everything seems fine this time.
Yeah.
Were you not going to check the room?
You went in there, didn't you?
You don't want to do the room anymore?
I don't want to do the room anymore.
You used to love the room!
I never loved the room!
You used to love going to the room!
I hate him!
Wait!
What?
Oh, okay.
The wheelchair is here.
It was here and it was like shaking.
Oh, so that was the anomaly.
It was the wheelchair.
It was, but good thing there was an actual anomaly.
Alright.
I don't think there is any.
I don't think so either.
I think we're good.
Which would suck because we're about to hit a milestone, I think.
Yeah, we're about to hit number 110.
110, baby!
110!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Is the light always like this?
Oh no, that's the orange light.
It's the orange.
Guys!
Doki, come on!
It's the orange light.
You can't even keep your own story straight.
You thought the person running after you was me!
I don't know.
I didn't know what to expect.
May, June, July, we care about your health.
Wait, everything looks normal.
I think so too.
I don't see anomalies.
Anomalies.
Coffee.
Water.
The vending machine looks the same.
Yeah.
Paintings look the same.
Oh!
Look, look, look!
Come in here and look up.
Oh, run, run, run!
Oh, okay.
We're running.
We're running, we're running, we're running.
We understood the rules.
We're running, we're running.
Alright.
Up we go!
I like how we have a retry.
We're like, we don't know, but like...
I know, right?
But let's just re-roll.
It's like, gotcha, we re-roll.
The anomaly.
Okay.
Fire extinguisher seems normal.
Exit seems normal.
Yeah.
Paintings.
Paintings seem normal.
The meds are all there.
Because someone's still not taking their meds.
It's not me!
I don't know!
Wait, is something...
Is something different in here, or am I crazy?
Let me check.
I mean, we all know you're crazy, but like...
But am I like crazy?
But you're like Manhera Manhera.
I'm like, are you the good Manhera?
Or the bad Manhera?
The ones that are like...
She might be crazy, but I think I can fix her.
And then the bad one was like...
There's no fixing her.
I'm just here for the wild ride.
I think we're good here.
I think this is normal.
I think so too.
The coffee all look the same.
There's one clock.
There's all the coffee stuff.
The calendars look the same.
Yeah, I think we're fine.
Doki makes me Manhera, you guys.
What do you mean?
I literally taught you how to use your own steam.
If anybody's going Manhera.
Okay, yay!
1-1-2!
1-1-2, baby!
I think we are going to 666.
No way.
There's no way.
Why are we at 100?
We are already at 100.
Yeah.
Maybe it'll go from 112 to like 500 or something.
The devs did not program enough.
There's no way.
There's no way there's enough anomalies to make 666 floors.
And it'll be like next patch update we added more floors.
It's just like the spooky...
The DLC floors.
Let's see.
I don't think I see anything.
I don't either.
The ceiling looks normal.
The meds are still there.
No one's taking them.
Wait, wait, the water cooler.
Oh, look at that.
My chat's helping now.
What water cooler?
The water cooler.
What about it?
Is it this water cooler?
Which water cooler?
Oh, the room?
Oh, no.
I even walked up to the other ones.
Oh my god.
666.
666 just like the doors.
Thanks.
My chat is doing their part.
Thanks, chat.
Thanks, dragoons.
My chat said it too.
They said in the room.
Yeah, but my chat said the water cooler.
My chat probably said the water cooler.
I probably said it too.
And I'm just not looking.
Oh, so you're not reading your chat?
Yeah, I'm neglecting them a little bit right now.
Sorry, chat.
It's okay.
They're not so needy.
Not like dragoons.
Wisps are, you know, they're chill.
The wisps are just as needy as the dragoons.
Stop saying she hates us.
Stop, stop, stop.
Oh my god.
She's supposed to be chill.
Okay, no.
Okay, we care about your health.
The medical center.
I think this is a...
Fire, exit, exit, water, fire.
This seems to be an okay room.
Guys.
I think so.
Besides you.
Wow, what's that supposed to mean?
We're here for you.
You haven't taken your meds since floor one.
We're here for the both of you.
Maybe all the triplets are fucked up.
Alright, 1-1-4!
1-1-4!
Yay!
We haven't failed even once.
This is crazy.
Yeah, just like for VOD watchers, skip the first 30 minutes.
Skip the first 30 minutes, but we haven't failed once.
Hey, June, July.
Yeah, we haven't failed.
I think the calendar will have anomalies soon.
Because I feel like the words are gonna change on the calendar.
Oh!
There's an anomaly.
There's an anomaly?
Yeah.
Go check.
See if you can find it.
Come on.
I found it, you find it.
Exit.
Oh!
There's the devs!
Is that the dev?
Yeah, I think it is.
It's the dev on this PC.
Oh, you're right!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's watching us play!
He's actually moving!
Oh my god!
Ew, he's smiling!
He's on our PC!
He's watching us.
Oh my god, is this like what it feels to like when we see our chat watch us at the panels?
This is what I see when I end the stream.
Now it's just sad!
1, 1, 5!
We're here!
Okay, nice!
When are we getting another SCP?
Yeah, where's your other SCPs?
Okay.
Checking the calendar.
Seems normal.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
Min, we care about you.
You gotta please take your meds.
Ah!
Tor!
Look, he cares about your health, Min!
He cares about your health!
The shadow man!
He's here!
Okay.
This is a really tall hospital, not gonna lie.
I know!
How many sick people are there?
I think they have other things to worry about.
If they need to make a hospital this big.
May, June, July.
It's like the only hospital in the country.
They've abolished all the hospitals and just kept this one.
I think...
I think we're fine.
We haven't even been in here.
Has there always been this many plugs, outlets in the hospital?
I don't know.
I wasn't looking.
You've been to a hospital before.
I have!
Oh my god, I thought that was you and Hera.
Wait, he's too big!
I was gonna say, he looks different!
He looks huge!
Oh my god!
He drank a lot of milk!
Brother, we're all supposed to be the same size!
Brother!
No, wait!
I think we're just small!
We're small!
Wait, are we getting smaller?
I think we're getting...
Wait, we got it!
We're not gonna be able to reach them!
We gotta hurry back or we're gonna go back to the pool!
They also shrunk.
Oh my god, we like grew back up!
Oh no!
It's SCP's dad!
No, please, god, no!
Where are you?
I saw a maze for a second.
Yeah, me too!
Oh no!
Wait, where are you?
There's things coming out!
Come back!
Wait, what's the maze rule?
That's not it!
I'm losing!
Listen!
Wait, you're dead?
You're dead?
I'm dead!
He touched me!
Oh my god!
You just have to avoid him!
Oh god, there's a ton of them!
There's a ton of them!
Run around!
Face through them!
You're a ghost!
Oh, they stopped.
Hey there!
Oh!
I gamed.
I'm a gamer.
Okay, so I saw the dead end, and I ran back to the dead end.
Why did you do that?
You might as well just say goodbye to me.
We have a new room!
Wait, maybe?
Oh, it's 200!
We're at 200!
Yeah, we have a new room at the end this time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, no, no.
It's the other door.
Yeah, it is the other door.
The other door is open.
Wait, so this is all the normal.
This is the normal.
Yeah, this is the normal.
We gotta figure out the... Oh my god!
Oh, there's our brother!
He finally got into the... He's not even on the exam table!
He has a bullet in his neck!
He has a tumor in his neck!
Oh my god, what happened to you?
Oh my god, brother!
Brother!
Brother, no!
This is how we find out!
No, at 400!
Oh my god!
Is that a bullet or a tumor?
I can't tell.
It kinda looks like a bullet, right?
I think he got shot in the neck?
That's why he can't speak!
They got his throat!
No, brother!
You have to talk to us!
Brother, we're worried about you!
But the doctors...
You just need to wait 10 more hours and the doctors will be here to help with the surgery!
It's just a bullet!
Don't worry about it, man!
Don't mind the fight!
Don't mind the fact that we're in a...
Don't mind the fact that this is where all the dead bodies go, brother!
And it's possible to save you!
Yeah, why is the...
Why is the morgue in the same place?
That's the x-ray?
What's happening?
Oh, it's Mortary Assistant!
We're back, baby!
Oh no!
We're back!
So these... there's three open.
Okay, one...
No, there's four.
Three wide open.
This one.
Oh, I'm sorry for the details.
I wanted to...
I wanted to provide the details.
I mean...
If we're like looking at...
Okay, then it's not four, it's...
Five, six open!
It's six open if you wanted the details!
There we go!
That's what we want!
We're here to spot the anomalies!
I really like that they kind of try to spruce up this room with some plants.
Oh yeah, some plants and be like...
You know, you might be dying, but at least there's like something to look at.
And the smiling...
The smiley face right here.
Everything's okay!
It's all good!
You're not gonna die!
We have the...
What is this?
Oh no, it's French.
Sous aux lectrices.
Wow.
You like my French?
It's authentic.
Sous?
Oh, Sous, I'm sorry.
Sous.
You don't know that!
You don't even speak French!
Ah oui.
Parlez-vous...
Parlez-vous franais?
Ah oui.
Je m'appelle Doki.
That's how you say Doki in French, by the way.
Doki.
Je m'appelle Doki.
It's like...
My name is Toby Fox.
I didn't say that!
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, this is apparently CPR.
Because they're kissing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they're kissing.
We're gonna do that to our brother?
Preparation and execution.
We're gonna kiss the bullet away.
We're gonna suck it out of his throat.
Like a vacuum cleaner.
That's what brothers do!
They suck the bullets out of their...
Yeah!
Get yourself a true brother!
And I'll suck the bullet out of your neck.
If you don't kiss your brother, for him to leave, you're not a real brother.
That's true.
Wait, was that always there?
The yellow sign thing?
Oh, I don't know, actually.
I think so.
Was that always there?
You sure?
Um, there's an anomaly.
Oh, shit.
Why are you running backwards?
Oh, my bad.
Why did you run so far away?
Okay, at least I didn't die!
Like someone.
You didn't even see the body bag.
I literally said, there's an anomaly.
I literally said, oh, there's an anomaly.
And then I saw it first.
Yeah, but you stayed there.
No, I literally...
You pushed me back into the room.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I can't push anybody back.
That is he says, she says.
He says, she says.
Sally sells cheese shells at the shop.
I can't even say that.
You can't even say it.
What is it then?
What is it?
Sally sells sea shells by the seashore.
She says, she says.
She says.
Sally sells sea shells by the sea.
I'm sorry.
I was in ESL class.
And English is my first language.
And English is your first language.
Yeah, I was put in ESL when I was younger.
Yeah, you needed it.
You needed it, clearly.
I think this floor is good.
Yeah, I think so too.
I don't think there's any anomalies.
I don't think so.
That took a lot longer.
It was actually deciding if we were right or not.
Should we give her that one?
They don't want to give us the point.
Come on, game.
I don't think they actually figured it out.
I think I heard something, but...
Inside the room?
I don't know.
It sounded like flickering lights or something.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
This calendar has been the same thing over and over again.
Over and over again.
When is there something new on the calendar?
Brother.
Brother, why is there still a bullet in your neck?
Please talk to us, brother.
That's all we want from you.
We just want you to talk to us.
We want you to talk to us.
We miss you, brother.
We miss your singing, brother.
The meds are fine.
I think everything on this floor is fine.
The coffee is fine.
The clock still says six.
Thirty...
Six, six, six.
There's no sixes on the doors.
I was like, why is my chat doing smiley?
Is this because of the damn smiley in this room?
Yeah, because of the boredom.
Alright, up we go.
Two, oh, four!
Four!
Four, four, four.
Two, oh, four!
Yeah!
And then, like, we see the elevator, like, drop down.
I know, I would, like, literally cry.
We went through the maze.
Oh, anomaly.
What's the anomaly?
You have to go see for yourself.
Come on, let's go inside.
No, we gotta see it to get there.
I saw it, I saw it.
You go see it.
Oh, no, he's sad!
No!
He's sad now!
It's the bullet.
He realized it's terminal.
It's terminal.
Oh, well.
We can have another brother.
Oh, my God.
Chill.
Ow!
What happened?
What's going on with you?
Go!
I'm letting my issues out because my brother's dying!
Come on, come on, Doki, we gotta leave the elevator.
We gotta go find the anomaly.
We gotta leave the elevator, come on!
Yeah, that's right, Kat hit me back into the elevator now.
I'm in the corner.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, he's happy again!
Yippee!
Oh, wait, what the fuck is that?
Go in.
I saw it.
Where's the anomaly?
I see him.
Closer to it.
No, you get closer, you get closer.
You found it, you should get closer.
No, no, no, no, that's not the rule because last time you didn't do that either.
What are you talking about?
We did it together, we're a team.
Okay, we're a team.
That's all we have now.
We're a team.
My brother's dying.
What are you doing?
Come on, get over there.
I don't think I can smack you anymore.
You reached your quota.
Well, get closer.
It's just a man with a brain.
It's the opposite of us.
Is he like, clipping through?
EC class, that's where our brain is.
I actually can't tell if it's like a headless guy.
No, he's like, clip through.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
He's like, clip through.
Come on, let's get closer, let's get closer.
Come on.
What do you want to say?
Hi.
I think he's just chilling in there.
He's just smiling.
Wait, I don't think...
Is that a brain or is he wearing like a handkerchief on his head?
Oh, yeah.
It's a handkerchief.
It's a handkerchief on his head.
I was like, wait a minute, that looks like claws.
He didn't come after us, it's fine.
Yeah, he was just saying hi.
He looked really like sinister though.
Yeah, he was just like, hey.
That's what he does on his free time.
What?
All right.
Hide in.
Okay, it's your turn to go to that room.
I'm going to look at the other anomalies.
Oh, I found the anomaly.
Oh, okay.
You go in there.
Never mind.
Come on, come on, come on.
What do you mean?
What am I?
Come on, get the anomaly, come on.
What the fuck is that?
Wait, that's just a kid.
It's just a kid.
It's literally just a kid.
They get like kid PNG on Google.
No, it's a kid.
It's like just a kid.
What's he doing in there?
What are you doing?
It's like a doctor's, like the children's hospital.
To make it seem more friendly, they put a child in the lights.
It's like a skibbity.
A skibbity?
Oh, no.
I thought you were...
This is when like boomers try to relate to the young people.
They just say random things.
Skibbity.
You can't just say skibbity all the time, Doki.
Oh my god.
No!
Um, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
I gotta die.
Go in there, I dare you.
What you mean, I dare you?
Oh fuck.
A double dog dare you.
A triple dog dare you.
Come on, go in there, go there, go there.
A quadruple dog dare you.
Come on, go in there.
Go in there, go in there.
A quadruple duck!
Oh, you got lucky.
You got lucky.
I guess I can go in there.
I mean, if you insist.
Isn't it working?
Oh my god.
It's like, a triple duck dare you to jump over that cliff right now.
You were too baby.
You couldn't even go in.
Oh yeah, as the blades are rolling down.
Oh my god, you're too baby.
I went in.
I went in the door shut.
It was like, so crazy.
Well, it wasn't you went in.
I punched you in.
Yeah, that's really true.
These rooms always have the anomalies.
They're kind of crazy.
Yeah, I think it's because like...
I think like, the devs ran out of ideas for the main area.
So they just put it all in here now.
Maybe we've exhausted all of them.
Like, we've seen all of them.
They're like, please leave the hospital.
We're done here.
I don't think there was an anomaly.
Did anyone see anything?
Water.
I'm triple checking.
I'm gonna go look at this sign.
The coffin sign.
I'm gonna look at the painting again.
I think it's done.
Floor.
Water.
This floor is always wet.
Where's the fucking janitor?
What do you mean this floor is always wet?
There's the wet sign.
It's been here since the beginning.
Why is every floor wet?
Wait, no, we're not.
What do you mean?
Has this page always been like peeled off?
What page?
This one.
Has this page always been peeled off?
I think so.
I don't think they would do something that subtle.
Okay, no, it's this.
666!
Never get...
You will never get 666.
Never get 666?
Is that what it says?
Yeah, you will never get 666.
Oh, you will never get 666.
Okay.
I'm gonna prove you wrong.
Yeah.
We told you this was a 24-hour stream.
Oh my god, it's actually gonna go to 666.
I told you!
This floor is 666.
Oh my god.
You know, I honestly thought this was gonna be like a short game.
I thought so too.
I thought it was gonna be like 24.
It's just like the exit 8.
But we're actually going to 666.
But we like jump a lot.
What?
That's true.
You found it?
Isn't it the plaids?
We're both looking at the anomalies together.
Yeah, I'm finding them.
I'm finding them.
I found all of them.
I found every single one so far.
You haven't even...
Come on, this is a Wii game, Doki!
You have to help!
You said...
You were like...
I told you!
You!
Okay, okay.
You think there's no anomaly?
I don't know.
I think there's...
What?
I think there's no anomaly.
Oh.
Did you find an anomaly?
No, I think there's no anomaly.
I'm going back.
I'm going back to cover your tracks.
Mint!
Is there an anomaly in this room?
Yes!
What is it?
Can you tell me what the anomaly is?
The X-ray!
Yay!
Can you say X-ray?
X-ray!
Yay!
Can you say X-ray?
X-ray!
What?
Say that again?
Can you say the X-ray?
The X-ray?
The X-ray.
Here we go.
Oh my God.
You're like Boots and I'm Dora.
Okay.
I think all the anomalies are just in that room.
I'm going to go back to cover this room.
Okay.
We are going back.
We are going back to the elevator.
Oh my God.
Don't lie.
I didn't tell you.
I didn't say anything.
We just turned around.
Hey, at least I run out of the elevator.
You just walk out.
You crawl out like a baby.
Like you're waiting- That's not true.
I was- No, no, no.
You're waiting for me.
You're waiting for me to run into anything.
It's not weird!
No!
Nuh-uh!
Are we going to come into this room with me?
Who's the baby now?
I thought that was you again.
I thought somebody was running at you again.
I don't think there's an omni this time.
We don't know yet.
There really is nothing in the outside.
It's kind of crazy.
Yeah, I think all the stuff is now just in this room.
That makes it easier.
It really does.
Did you guys see this?
And before they actually add one anomaly outside.
Is there anything?
I really don't see anything.
I don't see anything also.
The chat was like, look up!
But there's nothing up top.
Oh, are we supposed to look up?
Gamers don't look up, you guys.
Yeah, guys.
If somebody adds stuff upstairs, then they're not a real gamer.
It's true.
They're a poser.
Check behind the standing whiteboard.
You know what, you're right.
I was looking there earlier and I forgot.
Wait, what?
There's still...
Okay.
There's what?
What do you mean look up?
They keep saying look up.
Stop.
I am not up.
They said look up!
I'm looking up!
There's like something up top.
Are they gaslighting us?
I think they're gaslighting you, yeah.
There has to be.
Everybody's saying look up.
No, they're saying gamer subs.
Oh.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Check it out.
Gamer subs.
Content keepers.
Use code boomer.
Oh, wait.
There's no...
I think we're good.
No, no.
Everybody keeps saying look up.
I don't know if they're fucking with us.
I don't know.
They're not saying that to me.
I think they're fucking with you.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
You're right.
I think so.
So, I guess there's no anomalies.
Right?
Cut.
All right.
Yeah.
Everyone keeps saying the smile.
Yeah, because...
What smile?
The smile in the room.
No.
Let's go back and look at the room.
I can't.
What?
They keep saying they're missing.
They're yelling that I'm blind.
What?
They're saying we're blind.
My chat is not saying that.
Are you sure you're not looking at your chat?
I am looking.
Oh, my God.
There's nothing here.
What is your chat saying about my chat?
They're saying she's getting gaslight.
Everyone's saying the smile.
What do you mean by the smile?
Where's the smile?
Don't punch me.
Don't take your aggression out on me.
Let's get you to bed.
What are you talking about?
It's doki.
Dragoons SMH.
So true, chat.
So true.
I'm so tired.
Dragoons, are you really going to let the wisp say that?
Fight.
And you know like the meme, the Simpsons meme with the monkeys fighting and then like the people surrounding them with money?
Okay, we're going to level 12.
It's going to be level 12.
212.
Okay.
Yeah!
Oh, I was getting gaslighted.
Okay.
1, 2, 3.
Don't take it out on me.
I can't, Dragoons.
You're really going to let the wisp do this to you.
The wisps are good.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
Wait a second.
Oh, nevermind.
What?
Oh, I thought something was different, but it doesn't seem...
I think everything...
Yeah, I think everything looks the same.
There's outlets here.
.
Wait.
We're the same height.
Oh, nevermind.
We're the same height as our brother.
Hey, everything looks the same.
Oh!
Wasn't this on the other side?
No, it was always there.
Nevermind.
Yeah, the car was always there.
What was it?
No, I meant this.
Oh, the chair?
No, this...
This...
Whatever this...
No, this was always here.
Nevermind.
It was always here.
I was thinking about this thing.
Like the little...
Gaslight?
Yeah.
The camera thing?
You can't trust nobody.
Not even yourself.
These games make you paranoid, man.
You think about it.
And they're like, where's the...
Where's the anomaly?
I know.
Where's the fucking anomaly?
But like...
Everything looks the same.
Yeah.
I think so.
I don't think there's any difference here.
It looks...
Looks normal.
Yeah, this looks normal.
I guess we go.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Are the tiles bigger?
I don't think so.
Can we look up?
I'm looking out!
I'm looking up!
I looked up!
I looked up.
We're good.
All right.
Here we go.
Next floor.
Yay!
2, 13!
Wait.
People are saying there was an extra light switch.
Uh-oh.
Don't say that.
2, 13!
Wisps!
What the hell?
The wisps are gaslighting you too!
There was...
Oh.
I found the anomaly.
I found it too.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Okay.
I don't...
I don't want to go in that pool.
I think...
I think our brother is getting his operation right now.
Finally!
That means it's been five hours.
Yeah.
He went through two different rooms.
I don't even know what light switch they mean.
I think they just made it up.
Oh, these two maybe.
Oh.
So there's always been two.
Always been two.
Brother!
Did they take off...
Take away the bullet?
He says...
I think they did.
I think he looks a little happier now.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
I think he looks a little happier now.
I see.
Can you see that smile?
Oh!
There's a QR code.
Guys, scan that QR.
What is the QR?
Is it to like this YouTube channel?
I know it.
It's getting darker.
Is it?
Oh, it is.
Yeah.
Guys, scan that QR code.
Scan the QR code.
Where's it going to?
Where's it go?
Oh my God.
It's fully dark now.
Where does it go, guys?
Scan it.
I bet you it goes to...
It goes to like YouTube.
My affiliate link.
Yeah.
Someone's gamer subs.
Someone just said, I got a virus.
Hold on.
I'm...
My chat was like, hold still.
We can't scan it because you're moving.
It's a YouTube link.
It's a YouTube link?
Is it?
Where does...
Oh, it's a Rickroll.
No way.
It's a Rickroll.
Wait.
It has...
No way.
Hold on.
Are you going to scan it?
Is it actually a Rickroll?
No.
You can play it on your stream now.
It's like a five second...
It's like a five second clip.
It's unlisted.
Oh.
What is it?
I don't know.
It's a black screen.
I can't...
I can't figure out.
Put that volume up.
I'm trying.
Hold on.
I'm going to watch it again.
Oh my God.
It's disappearing.
What did he just say?
What the fuck?
Can you hear me?
Wait.
Hold on.
Yeah.
I heard it.
I heard it on your end.
Okay.
I'm...
What?
I can't...
I can't hear him.
Wait.
Play it again.
I'm turning off my noise gate.
So...
Okay.
Can you hear me?
I'm trapped in the game.
Oh!
Oh my God.
There's another VTuber in here?
I think we need to leave then.
We need to get out.
How dare they come to our stream.
This is an exclusive collab.
Yeah.
What are you trying to do coming to our stream?
I can't...
Is this a rigroll?
People on chat are saying it's a rigroll.
I know.
They didn't even bother to scan it.
Look see, I went into that room first because I'm brave.
Fuck you.
All right.
This is the same...
Oh!
Our brother...
Our brother has been possessed.
Wait.
What do you mean?
Our brother...
Stop punching me.
Oh!
Oh my God.
He's only looking at me.
And I think he's obsessed with my voice.
Whoa!
Brother, no!
It's not Alabama!
It's not Alabama, brother!
That bullet's the thing, Sam!
Don't say that!
Uh-oh, wait.
Isn't it normally at 16 that we get to the...
When do we get to the...
I think at 16 we do, yeah.
Yeah, so we have to get through this one.
I think... everything looks the same.
You say that literally two seconds into walking into the room!
You say everything looks the same.
That's how much I need.
That's all the intel I need.
It's one room.
You would have never noticed, brother.
You never would have noticed.
Yes, I would have!
No, you never would have noticed.
If I looked away, I would have seen him.
You never pay attention to brother anymore.
You never pay attention to him.
Oh, yeah?
You were the one that was supposed to look after him when he got shot.
I can't.
You know what?
I think you were the one who shot him.
You're the one who shot him!
You play Apex!
You knew I was going to supermarket for mom!
Supermarket for mom to do, to buy us groceries.
Dude!
Wait, I think there's actually no anomalies.
Brother was in your care when this happened.
That was trapped in the haunted hospital.
We only call him brother.
Yeah, he doesn't even have a name.
He doesn't even have a name.
Brother...
It's because he can only say brother, so we named him a brother.
He's like a Pokemon.
You know, like go brother go!
Go brother, go!
Brother?
Brother!
I think we're good.
There's no anomalies, right?
Yeah.
I don't think so.
Yeah!
It's like the Sean situation all over again.
Sean!
Press F to brother.
Uh-oh.
Are we about to go into the SCP world?
SCP time.
Oh god.
2-17.
Wait!
Wait, what's up?
Where are they?
Bro!
This is your fault.
No way!
This is your fault!
What?
Wait, can we go back?
Hold on, hold on.
16 floors again!
No, no, no, no, no.
What if it goes back to like 100?
We can just go back up again.
What does it go up?
What did you do?
I...
What did you...
What did you do?
Oh.
Okay.
When an elevator just gives us question marks, I don't think that's a good sign.
Okay, you go, brother.
Wait!
The elevator door is closed on the other end!
What did you do?
I'm going.
Why is the elevator closed?
I don't know.
Brother?
Brother, what did you do?
Brother, what did you do, brother?
Brother...
Why are you not going inside, brother?
I don't see anything in here.
Is it like patient zero?
Are we back to zero floor?
Oh, someone said we're checking your mistake.
Oh!
Where did we mess up?
This is the test floor.
The scale?
The scale was never here before, right?
I thought it was.
I even looked at it.
You can review the floor.
No, this is the test floor.
Oh wait, or like the floor that we messed up?
Yeah, I think this is the floor we were just at that we messed up.
Oh.
What did we mess up on?
Where did we mess up?
Oh, it was.
The scale was never there.
What?
Oh no!
No, I found it.
I found it.
Oh.
They're sad at our mistakes.
Yo, this is so messed up.
That's so messed up.
We have to do all 16.
Okay, no, it's a fast speed run because they're all in the same room.
It's always in that room.
That's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can do this.
Come on.
We can still get into speedrun.com.
Oh, what just happened?
Oh, okay.
We just spammed it.
200.
Okay.
Go.
200.
We got 200.
We got speedrun.
My screen went black.
Oh no.
Wait, can you see anything?
Yeah, I can now.
Okay.
All right.
Is there anything in there?
Do you think it's going to be the same stuff as before?
Okay.
I feel like it's just randomized.
Well, that means we know what to look for, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
We've seen majority of it.
We've seen all 16.
Yeah, we should know.
We should know what to do.
Yeah, right.
Yeah.
All right.
So, next floor.
Next floor.
Oh, but 200 is always the test floor.
Remember that.
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
So, there's nobody.
Nothing here.
There's nothing here.
We're stuck.
We're sorry.
We fucked up.
So, we recorded.
Oh, my God.
Brother, we're sorry.
We messed up.
Brother.
Oh, don't push me in.
It's this.
Yeah.
What floor is it?
It's the saws that come from the ceiling.
Oh, you looked up?
Yeah, I looked up.
I wasn't a gamer.
Oh.
All right, brother.
I know.
We're going to get you out of here, brother.
Why did you push me?
Brother, we're going to get you out, brother.
Brother is possessed.
All right, brother.
Possessed.
Let's go.
Speed run.
God, why is it 16?
I can't believe on the last floor we fucked up.
I know, right?
On the last fucking floor.
That means we have to check the behind the thing every time unless it's obvious.
Yeah.
Oh, the guy is in the locker.
Oh, we have the handkerchief guy.
Yeah.
Maybe they'll give all of them to us.
Maybe all 16 is just anomalies.
I can't believe we know every single anomaly now.
Yeah.
I mean, it's easy because it's like always in that room.
Where's the replayability?
Go, go, go.
Wait, wasn't one of them a girl?
What do you mean?
That like shows up?
Oh, the body bag.
Yeah, that follows.
I know where it starts at though.
I know where it starts at.
All right.
Oh, the x-rays are upside down.
I'll be the elevator pusher.
Are you?
No, you're not going to be.
Okay, we'll take turns.
We'll take turns.
You go next.
You'll go next.
What do you mean we take turns?
Yeah.
You're faster.
No, no, no.
I think you're...
No, no.
You go.
I think you're really good at this.
Okay, now you go and I'll press the button.
What if I mess up?
Just go.
Go hurry up.
I run in there.
Oh, my God.
Why are you so slow?
You know what everything is.
You literally made me do this.
I'm going to do it my way.
Check behind the whiteboard.
No, there's nothing out behind the whiteboard.
I don't trust you.
I don't trust...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you don't trust me.
Look at that.
You don't even trust me to do your job.
Okay.
I think we're good.
Wait.
See?
At least I'm meticulous.
No, we got to go to the other side, right?
Oh, yeah.
We got to go.
Yeah.
See?
I was testing you.
I was testing to see if you remember.
All right.
Okay.
That sucks because now we have to run all the way to the other side.
I know.
Yeah, because what if there's an anomaly?
Two.
Oh.
Seven.
Don't worry.
I'll be here.
What if it's the body bag?
Wait.
Why am I going?
Because then we know if there's an anomaly.
Okay.
It is a very far run.
It is a pretty far run.
I'm scared of being in here.
You're peeing in here?
Being in here?
Wait.
I think we're good, actually.
Oh, no.
That's the QR code.
It's the QR code.
Oh, it's the QR code?
Yeah.
The guy who's trapped?
See?
Look.
It would be a waste of time if I ran in there, too.
Oh, no.
I'm scared.
Get out of my way.
How did you know?
I said being, you guys.
It's Doki that brought up the pee.
I can't believe it.
All right.
You go.
Why do boys bring up the pee?
Run.
Why me?
Because we're taking turns.
I did not agree to that.
I hope it's the body bag.
If it's the body bag, we have to do this all over again.
No, we don't.
You just run over here.
Get in there.
Okay.
What if I die?
Go inside.
Oh.
It's the sad face.
He's sad.
Okay.
Sad face.
Yeah.
He learned he was terminal.
So, we have to get a specialist.
One of us is going to get the body bag.
It's going to be really unfortunate.
It's like Russian roulette for the body bag.
It really is.
Okay.
I'll go.
You get the body bag.
I sure hope not.
Yeah.
Okay.
I know where it's at though in the beginning.
So, okay.
It's not fair.
Wait.
That's not fair.
You know where it's at.
I'm not going to tell you either.
Wait a second.
But, make sure it's not the child too.
Oh, wait.
Not the child.
I don't see anything actually.
Oh, okay.
I think we might be...
Check behind the white board.
I did.
Okay.
Are you sure?
I don't think it's anything.
Yeah.
Seems good.
All right.
Let's go.
Nice.
If we fuck up, we know who to blame.
You could have checked.
You literally could have taken the two seconds to go in there.
I trust you.
I don't doubt you like you did to me.
Okay.
Two ten.
I trust you.
Your turn.
All right.
My turn.
Go in.
Go inside.
I'm going in.
Nope.
There's nothing there.
Behind the white board.
I checked it.
I checked the white board.
Check for the 666.
You will never get out.
I checked the 666.
There's nothing here.
Are you sure?
Oh, you don't trust me again?
There's no baby face.
No baby face.
Oh, you're coming inside the room too?
I mean, I'm right next to it, you know?
Wow.
You don't even trust me.
No, I don't.
I gave like full commitment to all your sources.
I was like, yep.
You said there's nothing.
There's nothing in there.
All right.
I don't even need to check.
Okay.
Because it's so long.
I'm going to be on the far side of the room.
I think we should go in the next one together.
All right.
You know what?
Let's...
Yeah.
I agree with that.
We'll go in the next one together.
Yeah.
We'll do that together.
See, guys?
This is what friendship is.
This is teamwork.
This is teamwork is dream work.
All right.
Okay.
Let's go.
All right.
I'm right beside you.
Okay.
I'm just...
Yeah.
Let's go.
All right.
We're back in brother's privacy.
Okay.
You know?
We have to give him his privacy.
He's getting operated on.
He's getting operated on, you guys.
It's so rude to go in there.
He's like naked right now.
Our brothers won't look.
Okay.
Let's go again.
All right.
Together.
Why do you keep looking back?
I think it's the body bag.
It's not the body bag.
Okay.
There's no child.
I hope it's nothing so that we can get closer to the room.
Yeah, me too.
I don't think there is anything.
I don't see anything either.
Chat!
Yeah.
I looked up.
Thanks for the raid!
I don't know who raided me.
Brother?
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, I'm going backwards.
I think we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Brother?
Don't worry, brother!
We're gonna make it to the 300th floor!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Yay!
Oh, blades!
Thank you!
213!
Now we took turns again.
Oh, it's the child face.
It's the child, okay.
God damn it.
Okay.
Alright, don't kill your turn.
Take care!
Go on in guys!
Guys!
No!
It's you!
It's all you!
What happens if we get there?
Go on in!
Oh!
There's no body bag!
Dang it.
Oh, you don't trust me!
You never touched the next unquote body bag!
You go right in!
It's 666!
It's the 666!
Yeah, yeah!
I think the next one is the body bag!
The next one has to be the body bag!
You just really have two left!
It's your turn.
It's okay, because if it's the body bag, I can see it from here.
I'll let you know immediately.
I'll be next to the button.
It's the body bag.
We're
on this side, you know?
Okay, this one has to be the smiley then, right?
Because we haven't gotten...
Oh, yep.
There it is.
Oh my god, that's so cheap.
The last floor with the smiley.
He must have done it so that the last floor would always be like...
The smiley face.
There's nothing.
SCP time.
No, no, no, no.
What's happening?
I can't see anything.
What is that?
What the hell?
It's like the Unity Store zombie.
But there's like a guy blocking the door too.
There's two of them.
There's two zombies.
Okay, wait.
We gotta split up.
Okay, the zombie is chasing me.
I'll sacrifice myself to you.
What do you mean, shit?
I got started chasing... getting chased by a zombie.
Oh, they're coming after me.
They're coming after me.
Oh my god.
They fucking ran to me.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you walking dead me.
What does he mean?
You let that guy kill you.
I literally watched him bum rush you.
Oh, we have a new floor.
We have a new door.
Alright, time to see.
Here we go.
What's all different in this room?
Okay.
Brother.
He's a doctor now.
He's a doctor.
No, he's at the... he's finally... he's getting his diagnosis.
Wait.
Oh gosh.
This is gonna be so bad.
We have to check behind these curtains.
Oh no.
No.
There has to be somebody behind these.
There's gonna be something on the computer.
There's gonna be people behind.
Oh god.
Okay, so like... he's waiting for the doctor to tell him...
If the surgery was like... if the surgery was a success.
Was a success or not.
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah.
It's the operation time.
Oh my god, brother.
Post operation.
Brother, we're here for you.
Yeah, we're holding your hand, brother.
We're holding your hand.
We're here for you, brother.
Washing your hands.
Drying your hands.
Isn't that like kind of unsanitary?
The hand dryer?
Where?
The hand dryer next to... yeah, I think the hand dryer doesn't do as well.
Those have like so many germs in them.
It's like...
That's true.
And then like...
He's pregnant?
Our brother?
Congratulations, brother!
Brother!
The bullet was actually a baby!
Baby!
Ty!
You're gonna be a mother!
The first ever throat birth.
You're like this hairball.
You cough like a child.
I just noticed this room is like in the middle.
So no matter what we do...
Oh yeah.
No matter what.
We have to run over there.
I can't believe this is actually 666.
But it's really like... oh my god, brother scared me.
It's really like...
It's like 16 floors each.
I think it's 15 technically, cause the...
Oh, I see the anomaly.
Wait, yeah.
Oh, what the fuck?
They're babies!
It's his baby!
Oh my god!
It's triplets!
It's...
I'm like, are you already at the elevator?
Yeah, because we saw the babies.
I'm not ready for this.
It's one for each of us.
I'm not ready to be a mom.
I'm not!
We're uncles now!
We're uncles!
Brother.
I can't believe it!
Congratulations, brother!
It's like how triplets are predisposed to...
Wait, what was that?
You heard that?
Did you hear that?
Yeah, I heard that.
Check behind.
I'll go right side.
Okay, and also go the left side.
What do you mean also?
I chose my curtain.
It's your turn.
Rock, paper, scissors.
Paper.
Rock.
Come on, go.
Oh, I heard it again.
I think it is in there.
Okay, I got an idea.
I was gonna like jump over here and look over the curtain.
Together.
We're all we had.
This is for you, brother.
I think it's saying here.
Oh, it's like...
Okay, I'm curious.
There's nothing here.
Wait, what?
It's just going...
Okay, so we're fine.
But that has to be an anomaly, right?
Yeah, that's an anomaly.
Someone said look up.
Is it up on the...
Okay, they all always say look up.
There's nothing up.
Is it on the computer?
No.
Oh, I heard another noise too.
He went...
I think it's just the same thing.
You're just projecting.
Hey, Dev, if you need anybody to make noises for your...
Thank you for the rain!
I didn't do it for free.
Thank you!
Alright, where do we go?
Thank you so much.
I don't think I see anything.
You looked for two seconds.
Oh, wait.
Was this computer always on?
I see something.
That's a cool effect, actually.
That's cool.
That's actually a cool effect.
Whoa, look at all these eyes.
Oh, they blink!
They gave me goosebumps.
They were blinking.
That's just triggering my trypophobia.
Trypophobia warning?
Alright.
3-0-4!
Oh my god.
Yeah, go ahead.
Go ahead.
I'll go right side.
Nothing on the right.
You never go on the right.
Nothing here.
Oh, wait.
I have an anomaly.
What's the anomaly?
It's like that maze escape game.
Yeah, they're playing this game!
Wait.
It's going to the room.
Wait, uh-oh.
I don't want to see that.
Wait, are they out here?
You think there's someone out here?
No, they're in our room now.
They're looking at the anomalies.
Oh, and it stopped.
The game stopped.
Oh, okay.
They're not as gamer as us.
Yeah.
They got too scared and stopped playing the game.
We're never scared.
We made it to 305.
We're the first YouTubers to make it to 305.
Are we actually?
What do you think?
Don't lie on the internet, Dokie!
Here, I'll go right.
Okay, I'll go left.
Nope, no anomaly.
Anomaly.
There's an anomaly on the computer.
What is it this time?
Oh, hey!
There's like, insert your OC.
What are you talking about?
It could be you.
Those drawings where you buy art and insert your character here.
And the black screen is the character.
What?
Did we see the same thing?
Yeah, I saw it.
There was a black character out there.
It's a silhouette.
YCH, your character here.
I didn't see that at all.
What did you see?
I think you need to take your meds, girl.
No, I think you need it.
My chat saw the same thing.
Okay, I'll go left.
No anomalies here.
Girl?
Yeah, what the hell is Doki cooking?
I don't know, man.
She's overcooking.
Oh, you don't trust me.
You're looking at the left side because you didn't even trust me.
Okay, well look at the right side.
I think we should both double check our answers.
Wait, was the needle always this huge?
What needle?
I don't think there's ever been a needle.
I'll be honest, I haven't been looking at the desk at all.
Oh wait, was there always been like the disease...
Disease history.
Wait, maybe we should pay attention to this table.
Yeah, I feel like we should.
Wait, is there always a history-m?
History-m.
Okay, it's always been here.
Okay.
Is brother okay?
This doctor is just illiterate.
I think we're good.
I think we're good too.
Yeah.
History-m.
See, my chat said it was always there.
Someone said the plant.
What do you mean the plant?
The plant?
No, the plant is always there.
That green.
Three-oh-seven.
Bing.
Nice.
I hate it when it pauses after a while.
Because it's just like, what you mean?
It's bing, right?
Brother?
Right side?
Right side, safe.
Safe.
Left side?
History-m.
Streaming...
Floor, nothing.
Ceiling, nothing.
Exit.
Brother...
Water.
Planting.
Brother, not pregnant anymore.
He has had the babies.
He's had the babies.
It was...
It wasn't a bullet all along.
It was like an egg.
You are kidding.
What happened to the baby?
It's like being washed out there.
Yeah, they're in the baby ward.
The baby ward.
Yeah.
The ward for all you guys.
The big baby ward.
Alright, it's time.
Brother!
Still the same.
Oh.
Um...
Help me.
Help.
I'm gonna drown.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna...
The door is gonna open.
I'm gonna drown.
I'm gonna die.
The door is gonna open.
I'm gonna...
It's gonna open.
I'm gonna drown.
I'm gonna die.
You're doing great, sweetie.
See, I told you.
There we go.
God.
She's such an overreacting.
Those were...
Those were all my wisps tears when I don't start the stream.
She hates us.
What an overreaction.
It was saying that she was gonna die.
You know what?
I get those...
Those...
Those anomalies a lot.
I think it's because I'm not a big-ass, baby and I have to go into the room first.
Look at this.
Wait, has this always been white?
The floor?
It looks whiter than usual.
Yeah, it looks like extra bright.
Oh, um...
You might want to get out of there.
Why?
What?
What did you see?
Wait, what did you see?
Go back in.
Okay, you have to go back in until you find the anomaly.
No, no, no.
I already found it.
You go in.
It's the floor.
What did you...
Oh!
Ah!
Please stop the game if I get crushed!
So, I think the reason why it was whiter was because the ceiling was reflecting.
The ceiling was closing in.
It was getting brighter.
The light was getting closer to the floor.
We managed to avoid drowning.
Okay.
And getting crushed.
Okay, I went in first already, so it's your turn.
Okay, now it's my turn to go in first.
Brother, safe.
Computer, safe.
Right side, safe.
Left side, history-m.
History-m.
Lights, not crushing us.
Sink, di-jo-boo.
Blow dryer, still unhygienic.
Filled with germs.
I think...
I think we're safe.
Brother, give us a thumbs up if we're safe.
Then before we go in, let's go to the next room.
The most important thing is to, like, one anomaly outside.
I know, right?
I feel like we should still be checking.
But they didn't last time.
So...
Alright.
This is it.
Okay.
Alright.
311!
311.
Yeah!
How are hand dryers unhygienic?
Well if they're in a bathroom- Oh, you go in first this time.
Alright.
If they're in a bathroom, they just blow all the germs off.
...on to your hands.
Right side, nothing.
Left side, safe.
History...
History... PC.
Ground, nothing.
Sealing...
Brother, still there.
Brother, nothing in his brain.
Nothing going on in there.
Brother...
Brother's going through it.
Wow, there's no way there's not an anomaly here.
There's not no anomaly still?
Yeah, the poopy air gets blown around.
It's disgusting.
It's like when you have to change your toothbrush every couple of months.
Yeah, months?
Because like...
Yeah, every couple of months you have to change your toothbrush.
I thought it was more frequent than that.
Wait, how frequent?
Wait a minute.
How frequent is it supposed to be?
Someone said... I thought it was like every month or so.
Someone said three months max.
Okay, okay.
Wait, you change your toothbrush every month?
Well, like I've been getting sick a lot, so I've been changing it a lot recently.
Okay.
Not every year?
Not every three to four years?
It's like a mattress.
You're just supposed to flip it upside down.
You're not supposed to get a new mattress.
You just flip it.
Yeah.
Okay, for those who don't know...
Why I had to change my toothbrush every couple of months...
It's because like...
You know how you're using your bathroom and you're flushing?
Yeah.
If it's all in the same room, you're gonna want to change...
Wait.
What?
Is that alive?
Or...
Hey, hey, it's a good thing.
Oh, it's a cat!
You don't get to see the cat.
Oh, wait, there's one next to you!
There's one next to you!
He's...
Wait, what is happening?
Oh my god, he's dying.
He's just dying.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's another one.
There's another one over here.
There's a witch in the universe!
There's a one...
There's one under the couch too.
Wait, they're all just dying.
What's going on?
Dies of cringe.
They see us.
They're like, no documentary here.
Dies of cringe.
They haven't changed their toothbrush in over...
So yeah, you have to change your toothbrush every couple of months because when you're flushing, you know, stuff goes out.
You're ingesting that, man.
Yeah.
That's why you close your mouth.
You open your mouth?
When...
What do you mean?
When I brush my teeth?
How else do you brush your teeth?
Oh, okay.
It's not like, you know, when you're flushing, you like, mouth open and like...
No, I just mouth open over the seat, you know?
That's why...
That's why you gotta...
Six!
Where's the other six?
Where's the third six?
Six is here.
You found it?
Six is over there.
Six-six-six!
Six -six-six!
We're going to make it!
Someone's like, wait, you change your toothbrush?
No.
Oh, no.
You don't change your toothbrush until the bristles are all frayed?
What do you mean?
That's why I don't flush.
No!
All right.
Okay.
Oh, brother is huge.
Brother is huge.
I love how we could tell immediately.
We were like, brother, brother, we're supposed to be the same size.
Brother, you can't drink more milk than us like this.
Come on, man.
Yo, he's been doing too much protein shakes.
Brother, you've been going to the gym without us?
It's not fair!
Brother is going to join basketball.
He's on the hospital basketball team.
Oh shit, we're almost to 16.
We're at almost 16.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
He's big.
Okay, okay.
Okay, alright.
Brother's the same height.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, what the hell is that?
I think it's following you.
Does it rush over?
Oh, wait, what is going on?
Oh!
Wait, will it stab us?
I can't.
Oh, they're growing bigger!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's like a...
Oh, wait, it's cheesy!
Oh my god, it's protecting its babies!
It's protecting the babies!
It's like those...
That was...
It's like bears.
It was a brother.
Alright, last floor.
Last floor, baby!
Until we're at 400.
All we have to do is... the ones we're at 400...
Oh, yeah, definitely.
What's behind... what do you think is over there?
I'm going to look.
Let's look.
What is it?
Oh!
Oh.
What is it?
I don't want to die, though.
Because I don't want to redo everything.
No, there was nothing behind it.
There was nothing behind it.
Oh, there's nothing behind it?
Yeah.
You really check.
You could go look.
You actually check.
You don't trust me?
Come on.
No, I trust you.
I trust you.
I just wanted to show you.
Toki!
I can't believe you don't trust me.
I trust you.
You don't trust me.
You always look at the stuff I looked at.
I hope you don't die this time again.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry for sacrificing my life for you.
Wait, what's in here?
What's in here?
I don't know.
I just saw, like, PC monitors in the toilet.
Wait.
Oh, we have to open the doors.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh!
What the fuck?
That was your door!
Wait, but we just restart.
It's fine.
Uh-oh.
Sorry.
What do you mean?
Just run away.
Oh, Skippity.
Hey, Skippity.
Wait, actually...
Skippity!
Oh, you missed it.
Oh, Boomer missed it.
This one is empty, though.
I can't believe it.
The Boomer missed it.
Oh, it's flooding.
It's flooding.
Is that you?
No, that was not me.
I did not open...
Why does all the doors you open end up killing us?
It's not me!
What do you mean it's not you?
You...
Every door you open...
Just keep opening!
I am!
Who's laughing?
Oh, my God.
It's not going inside.
Oh, no.
We're gonna drown!
My toilet's laughing at me.
My toilet's laughing at me, too!
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
You found it?
Where, where, where?
Where are you?
Come on, hurry up!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Hurry up.
You don't even say where we're at and you say hurry up.
Thanks for the instructions there, man.
Wait, is this the same room?
Oh, no.
We're in the same room.
We're in the toilet now.
We're in the toilet.
Our brother needs privacy.
Brother!
Oh, we're gonna have to check inside every single...
I don't think so.
Oh, my God!
Look at us!
That's us!
Family portrait!
Look at family photo in the bathroom, everybody!
Meet and greet in the bathroom!
Six toilets?
There's six of everything.
There's even six sinks!
Oh, my God.
And there's six blow dryers.
Ew.
They're right next to the toilet.
They're gonna blow that into your hand.
Brother, do you have enough toilet paper?
I like how the kids sink is next to the urinal.
Okay, this one's gotta be easy.
There's like nothing in here, right, guys?
Yeah.
I think we got this.
It has to be.
Idle meeting time.
We can speed run this to 600.
We can speed run this.
Yeah.
We're literally so close to the end.
I think we're actually, yeah.
200 more floors.
We're like masters now.
Oh, my God.
We're the masters of the universe.
I don't know about that.
What do you mean?
The mirror will be fun.
The fastest.
Oh, don't say that.
Don't say that.
How would you know?
Check the mirror.
Oh.
Oh, there's blood.
There's more than just blood.
Those hands are like coming out of the wall.
Yeah.
It's like a PNG.
He's holding a PNG of the air vent.
They're supposed to be like behind the vent.
Wait.
Does that mean vents are fake?
Like they don't leave anywhere?
There's no ventilation?
Oh, my.
Wait.
There's no ventilation in the bathroom?
Yeah.
That's not hygienic at all.
All right.
That's how we don't say anything.
We just run around.
Just the 180.
I was like, all right.
That's an anomaly, right?
Doki, I have to pee.
Oh.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll do this for us.
Don't die in there.
Okay?
Don't.
Just stay there.
What if I just die?
Don't die.
Why are you still here?
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Hold on.
Hold on, guys.
Sorry.
Were you guys waiting to see if I get it?
Oh, okay.
There was no anomalies.
Wait.
Has there always been three trash cans down here?
Why is there a trash can down here?
I didn't look down, guys.
I didn't.
Guys.
This is the only way.
There's always been three trash cans.
I didn't look down.
Yeah?
Wait.
Why would the trash cans be here?
Okay.
There's always been three trash cans.
Two.
Four.
No.
We have to start counting.
Two.
Four.
Six.
Two.
Four.
Wait.
Where's five?
Two.
Four.
Six.
Okay.
Two.
Four.
Five.
Where's the six?
There's a six broom.
Two.
Oh.
Sorry.
Two.
Four.
Six.
Two.
Four.
Where's the six trash can?
Six.
Okay.
There's six of everything.
Two.
Four.
Five.
Wait.
There's five.
Oh.
Six.
That's a...
Okay.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
I think we did it.
No anomalies.
There's a seven urinal?
I don't know.
Two.
There's six urinals.
Someone can't even count.
All right.
I think we're good.
I think there's no anomalies.
Wow.
Min is so slow.
Of course.
Of course she goes to the bathroom when there's no anomalies.
Look at her.
Was there...
Yes.
There was six toilets because the whole game is based off of...
Six.
So there's six of everything.
Hold on.
I gotta get tea.
Min, don't come over here.
No.
Min.
There's no anomalies.
Get over here.
No.
You can't just...
What do you mean you have to get tea?
There's no anomaly.
If only I could just leave.
Oh my God.
Oh, I can push it.
You're right.
Oh my God.
Why didn't I push it?
Why didn't you guys tell that... say that earlier?
Oh my God.
I could have just pushed it.
I can't believe it.
I could have done that in the very beginning.
I messed up.
Wait.
No.
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
We're getting you to the other side.
Nice.
We did it.
We're professionals.
Okay.
I gotta...
I gotta like make sure.
Okay.
In case...
In case there's...
There is an anomaly.
Or there's no anomaly as well.
Okay.
No.
All right.
Here we go.
I'm gaming.
All right.
Everything looks the same.
I'm back.
Oh my God.
You scared the shit out of me.
I had to push you to the other side of the elevator.
Everything looks good.
There was no anomaly.
You had plenty of time.
You had...
I'm gonna chill.
I'm gonna double check.
I don't trust you.
What do you mean?
We're on the other floor now.
Oh.
Nope.
No.
What do you mean?
Oh.
Let me double check.
This is a new floor.
Come on.
Let's hurry it up.
I literally pushed you from one elevator to another.
All right.
Here we go.
Was she brave, you guys?
Be honest.
I was so brave.
I counted.
I learned how to count today.
Really?
I learned my ABC's.
You took your counting medicine.
Yeah.
I took my counting medicine.
Okay.
I just realized we have to count these items as well because like...
I also...
Yeah.
How many trash cans were there?
Six.
Six?
Okay.
Yeah.
It's six.
Oh, seven.
No, there's seven.
Two, four, six.
What do you mean?
There's six.
Someone didn't learn to count.
It's me.
I didn't learn how to count.
Someone didn't learn.
Two, four, six.
It's like in every single little stop.
I think we're good.
I think we're good too.
I'm pretty sure.
I think so.
Back to kindergarten.
Min didn't take her counting medicine.
That's okay.
Send me back to kindergarten.
Let me be a child again.
All right.
Yay!
4-0-6.
Oh, six.
That's pretty impressive you were able to punch me all the way.
I'm trying to make sure.
Yeah.
What was that?
It was the blow dryers.
Oh my God.
The blow dryer.
It scared me so bad I couldn't even make a noise.
I was like...
It's just like, whoa, shit.
I thought it was something chasing us.
We talked too much shit about the blow dryer.
Blow dryers, guys.
Okay.
All right.
We're still normal.
There's going to be something in here.
2-4.
Let's test her counting.
Brother.
2-4-6.
Oh, we have to make sure to look between the toilets too.
Yeah.
I looked in between.
Why is this toilet like filled with...
There's always...
Wasn't there always a toilet in here?
Yeah.
Isn't this like the handicap slot too?
Because it's a bigger doll.
Yeah.
So...
It's a bigger doll.
Yeah.
That's so messed up.
They did not care.
This is a hospital.
There's so many people in wheelchairs.
Yeah.
And yet they filled it up.
Look up.
I'm looking up.
2 -4 -6.
I mean, we counted everything.
There's six lights.
2-4.
Wait.
No.
There's eight lights.
Has there always been eight lights?
I don't think it's that meticulous, right?
I don't think so either.
Yeah.
There's a bloody handprint.
What do you mean bloody handprint?
Where?
Everybody's spamming handprint.
Handprint?
Is it in the toilet maybe?
Okay.
Did anyone spam handprint on your chat?
There are four lights.
What do you mean?
There's four lights.
Handprint by the kid's urinal.
There's a kid's urinal?
There is.
They're just saying that the...
Oh!
That's not a urinal.
That's a...
Wait.
There's also like a...
There's something...
Yeah.
There's something in the trash can.
Wow.
That's sneaky.
What?
Oh, that was a sneaky one.
Is it a hand?
I can't...
I'm trying to see it.
I think it was.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's a hand.
We're not shortened at the seat.
We're not a chat.
We now know someone in the chat pees in sinks.
Someone.
Someone uses the kid's urinal to pee in the sink.
I don't think it's versus allowed near the kid's hospital.
Someone's peeing in sinks over here.
Oh.
You're right.
In public.
You're in public.
What if you stand there?
I dare you to stand there.
Stand where?
Over there?
Wait.
There's a shadow over there.
Yeah.
Stand on...
I triple dog dare you.
I already dared you.
Oh.
It's gone.
It's back.
Wait.
That's your turn.
Oh.
It's gone.
You like absorbed him.
Yeah.
You too.
Even... yeah, we didn't get help from chat at all, like...
Yeah, yeah, we got like... we've like never failed.
We literally have never failed!
Yeah, we've been consistent throughout this.
This game is just a really long game.
Why do you run past the door?
Why did you say...
Oh!
Brother!
Brother, it's okay!
It's a miracle!
Brother has risen!
On the fourth day, he rises!
Metal Gear rising right there!
Oh my god, it's a miracle, guys!
Why do you always run past... oh, okay.
Someone peed in the urinals for me.
Someone actually peed in the urinals.
They mixed the juices up.
What are you talking...
What do you mean by that?
Only bros understand.
I don't think even bros will understand what you mean.
Only bros know.
Alright, let's see.
Don't run past, just run... just run inside.
What?
Wait, there's something weird.
Something weird?
Oh!
The caution signs are moving!
Yeah!
They're coming!
They're coming towards us!
Wait, they're coming after us.
Wait, they're actually coming after us.
Wait, what would the caution signs do?
Wait, let's see.
But what if we die?
They're converging.
What are they gonna do?
Fucking eat us?
They're converging.
It's like a... like a mating ritual.
We're watching a mating ritual right now.
Oh!
Nope.
I don't wanna... I'm not their...
I'm not their mate!
I told you, it does nothing!
Come on, it was a mate!
I think they'll block the entrance, I think, right?
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I think they're gonna block the exit.
Thank you for the rain!
The floor is wet!
Oh my god.
Maria!
Thank you for the rain!
The floor is wet!
The floor is wet?
Ew.
Mm-hmm.
From all the juices in the urinal.
Your words, not mine.
See, I told you, you knew what it means!
I knew it!
See?
Go ahead.
She knows what it means!
Don't run past the door.
Just go straight in.
Don't run past.
I've always... I've always walked in.
No, you haven't!
I don't know what you're talking about.
Literally every time!
She's rewriting history right now.
No!
She's rewriting history.
Two, four, six.
There's six trash cans.
I think it's no anomaly.
I think this one's good.
I can't tell...
I'm looking up.
Are the toilet seats up or are they normal?
Yeah, they've always been up.
Okay.
It's a men's urinal.
The urinal's a urinal.
It's different.
I mean, it's a men's bathroom.
I guess.
You okay, brother?
Those are cracked?
There's no doors that's cracked.
What do you mean?
All the doors have been cracked.
Yeah.
Someone was like, saw something.
What did you see?
Did you take your meds?
I saw something.
I saw you.
Nothing in the mirror.
There's six of everything.
Ah!
Are you gaslighting?
No, I'm not.
I'm not.
Woo!
He's like peek-a-boo.
Hello?
I'm lagging!
Oh!
Discord has been weird today.
No, my OBS is lagging too.
I think there's a big E in here.
I think there's a big one in here.
Donkey crash?
Oh no, I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
It was so scary.
It was so scary because I said that and then everything just stopped.
Everything stopped moving and I was like, oh no.
What happened?
Wait.
Are there more fire things than usual?
Two or four.
I mean you can literally count.
Was there always six?
There's six of everything.
Yeah, I mean.
Was there always six and six six six?
Oh my god.
That was so spooky.
Spooky.
Her stream is alive.
My stream is alive now.
I think there's nothing here.
There's been like not a lot of anomalies for this one.
Not for this one, no.
I mean it's like such an empty room.
What are you gonna do?
I think this one's like harder to have anomalies.
I think so too.
I think we're fine.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, I can't punch you.
You took your quota.
What happened?
Why can't I punch all the time?
How come we can't have six brothers?
I don't understand.
We can only have five brothers.
It goes up to four players.
Yeah.
Where's our...
Where's brother four, five, and six?
We went in the wrong elevator.
This was you.
No, it wasn't!
No, it wasn't you!
Let's away!
This was you.
No, I followed you.
I followed you.
You could have stopped me.
It's okay.
We can speedrun.
Handprint.
Oh no.
Check if the thing appears.
Wait, but what if there's new anomalies?
What if there's new ones that we don't...
Oh wait, no.
This is zero.
Oh, this is zero.
You're right.
No!
No, this is Chat's fault.
They should have told us.
They should have said...
They should have laughed at our jokes because we're just so funny.
Okay.
Thank you, game.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
We can speedrun.
What floor are we on?
How far did we get to?
We got to 13.
We got to 13, man.
What the fuck?
I dare you.
A triple dog dare you.
A quadruple dog dare you.
You know what?
I'm not afraid.
Oh my god.
I killed them.
You murdered them.
You didn't see anything.
You cleaned up the bodies really fast.
Oh my god.
You didn't see anything.
You killed them.
No, I did not, brother.
Remember, there's always been three brothers.
Remember that.
There's always been three brothers.
There's never been a fourth, fifth, or sixth brother.
It's the mating ritual again.
Oh, it's the mating ritual.
You're right.
Here they come.
This is why there's only three brothers.
I'm an accessory to murder.
They won't believe you.
Hey, but that was a new one, so that means...
That was a new one, yeah.
Okay.
We got this.
Speedrun, speedrun, speedrun.
We have to be careful of the head, though.
Peeking out.
I'll look at it.
I'm looking at it.
Okay.
Look through the cracks right now while we check.
I'm looking through the cracks.
I'm peeking.
I'm voyeuring.
I don't see anything, actually.
I don't see anything either.
Brother is still being brother.
This is why he doesn't talk.
He saw some stuff he wasn't supposed to.
He saw some stuff.
The mating ritual.
Okay.
Check for handprint.
I already looked.
We all looked.
Here we go.
4-0-5.
4-0-5, baby.
4-0-5!
Give it up for 4-0-5!
Bing!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Let's see.
Brother is still brother.
It's so loud.
It's so loud!
It's so damn loud!
I never expected...
No one ever expects the blow dryers.
At least we got it out of the way.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
We're okay.
We're almost back to 13.
Brother...
Brother is not performing any miracles right now.
I'm looking.
I'm checking.
What?
Check the doors.
Wow!
What the fuck?
He closed the door!
Stop!
Stop looking!
Stop looking at them!
Stop it!
She lets you look, but I can't.
Were you invited to something?
I think so.
But that was also a new one.
That was a new one.
I've never seen that one before.
That could have been 14, 15, and 16.
Brother.
Brother is not performing miracles.
No peek-a-boo.
We're missing one new anomaly.
I think so too.
Yeah.
No hands.
We can see our faces.
There's no hands coming from the vents.
I think we're fine.
No anomalies.
Okay.
Cool.
Alright.
Nice.
See?
We're so good at this.
Let's go.
We could have been at 4500.
Shut up.
We'll be there.
We could have been at 4500.
We'll get there.
Okay.
Alright.
Brother.
Brother sitting down.
Faces.
Handprint.
Alright.
Back to the elevator.
Bro.
We got a retweet going on now.
I know.
We have a system.
We're speedrunners.
Speedrun.com.
Sign us up.
Maybe don't.
Why are we speedrunning?
Because we...
No.
Because you...
Chat messed up.
Chat.
Brother is brothering.
We have faces.
There's the peek-a-boo.
Peek-a-boo.
Alright.
This is the slowest speedrun.
What do you mean?
I don't mean you.
What chat are we talking about?
What are you trying to plot?
I don't know.
I think there's only two chats here.
Brother is...
Brother comes after us.
Brother does not just...
Brother runs.
Brother walks.
A miracle.
The second miracle.
What if he came to the door?
What if he was just like...
He was trying to talk to us.
He was trying to communicate.
He was like, brothers.
Brothers, look at me now.
Brothers.
This is the one time I'm sentient.
Brothers, I have something very important to tell you.
Oh, it's the footprints.
Footprints.
Oh, it's the foot.
Alright.
This is the one time I can say whatever it is.
I've been keeping it in this entire time.
Oh my god.
We're almost safe.
Back to work.
We're still missing one more anomaly that we haven't seen before.
Because we got...
Because we were missing three and now we saw two of the new ones.
Yeah.
We need the...
This one is going to be the faces.
Nope.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
No urinals.
I don't see anything.
There's no hands coming out of the vents.
Nothing.
At least they don't make us count these.
I know.
I'm not paying attention.
I know it's all sixes, but I'm not paying attention.
Me neither.
Alright.
Four thirteen!
Back where we started!
Yeah, you're right.
Ding!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
What's this one?
No faces.
No blood in the urinals.
No hands coming out.
There's nothing.
Another... no anomaly?
Two in a row?
Two, four, six...
Come on!
You're getting a little lazy right now.
What is this?
We want an actual challenge.
This way.
Four fourteen!
Yippee!
The last three has to be the anomalies ones.
Because we're missing the faces, the hands coming out of the vents, and the blood in the urinals.
Yeah, we're missing those three.
So, easy peasy.
We got this, guys.
Alright, which one is this?
Hands!
Hands, alright.
You know what?
I bet you, you won't risk it.
We stay in the elevator for the last three.
Stay in the elevator?
Oh, me?
No, we press the buttons.
We don't even have to look at it.
Because the last two has to be anomalies.
You're a coward.
What do you mean I'm a coward?
I wanted to go into the room!
You know it's an anomaly!
But what if it's not?
What if it's not?
Blood in the urinal.
I knew it.
The last one has to be the mirrors.
Okay, then you can check.
It's too risky!
I'm going to do it.
How much do you want to bet?
I will bet money.
I will bet on Akasupa.
You know I'm right.
You don't want to bet.
You're wrong.
Why are you running back this way?
That's why I'm smarty.
I'm going to die immediately on this one.
So that...
Where are we?
We're in a janitor's closet?
Oh my god.
Why is it so dark in there?
I don't know.
Oh no.
We have to go downstairs.
I think we broke our ankles.
Okay, maybe we don't push each other then.
Maybe we can't actually.
You can't run?
You can't even run?
I fucking ran.
I broke my ankle.
There's something like humming.
I like ran and I broke my ankle.
What happened?
You are weak bone.
What happened to you?
I was born with glass bones.
Are you even watching?
There's a girl whispering.
She's humming.
Every breath I take is pain.
Shut up.
You weak willed woman.
Oh my god.
I'm so close.
Do I just walk?
Oh my god.
Wait, there's a face there.
There's a face?
Where?
Look at it.
It would be so funny if you look at it again.
Oh, okay.
I made it.
There's no face, you liar.
Yes, there is.
Why am I the only one that survives these?
Doki, you...
I'm sorry, my bones were made of glass.
Oh, you're gonna fucking bring up my medical history.
My brother has been demoted to being a janitor.
He's a janitor.
Okay, this is always in here.
This little head bag.
They're throwing away body parts.
Oh yeah, this little head bag.
Why are they throwing away body parts?
There's so many caution wets.
There's six brooms.
Six brooms.
There's six trash cans.
But there's only five sinks.
Oh, I feel like that's gonna be an anomaly.
They're just gonna bring a sixth sink out of nowhere.
And there's five trash cans.
There's five trash cans?
Oh, cause this is like floor 500.
We're so close.
We have 266 floors to go.
We're almost at the finish line.
I did not expect this game to be like three hours long.
Well, you know, if some chatters wouldn't you know, give us the wrong information.
Oh, you're so right.
If some chatters backseated us better.
Oh god, that actually That actually got me.
That actually got me.
That got me too.
Wait, that's the anomaly, right?
It started us over.
No, it's 501.
That's where we were at.
Yeah, so we go up.
That was the anomaly.
Oh, okay, then go up.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it had to be.
Kinda got me.
I was like, I just got a new PC last week.
What do you mean?
And I saw 666.
Yeah, you guys, it's the dragoons.
It's not you.
Don't worry.
Yeah, you guys, it's the wisps.
You know, it's always the wisps.
Go into the rooms.
Good, good, good.
It's both of us.
Wait.
Brother, brother, help us, brother.
Brother, brother, brother protect us, brother.
Brother, brother, brother.
Go big, go.
It's Johnny!
Is he gonna break it down?
It's Johnny.
Okay, that was good.
Yo, that was so good.
That was good.
I like that.
It's the perfectly cut rectangle in the door.
Blender rectangle.
Delete.
Let's go, let's go.
I wonder what it would have looked like on the outside.
I know, right?
I am pretty curious.
That was a good one.
That was pretty good.
You know what, Des?
You got that.
You can have that one.
I don't think there's anything here.
I don't see any anomalies.
The bags all have one.
Check the signs if they say any other 666.
I feel like every floor has a 666 somewhere.
Sometimes, someplace, somewhere.
Somewhere.
666.
Have you been counting all of these?
They're all five, right?
They're all five.
We're on the fifth floor.
The 500th floor.
The dev is so funny.
Alright, here we go.
Johnny goes in the square hole.
The Johnny goes in the square hole.
Go on in.
There's gotta be something in here.
Caution.
Nothing.
Nothing in the bag.
There's no 6s anywhere.
I feel like the 6s would be in the trash can.
Yeah, at the bottom of the trash can.
I don't see any body parts coming out.
I think we're good.
I'm going on the other side.
Okay, brother.
We're good.
Goodbye, brother.
Where are you?
I was just double checking.
You never trust me.
I'm just checking too.
Even though I was right.
Okay, if we go to 500, I'm just saying.
These were anomalies.
And you didn't trust me.
You're like, no.
You wouldn't have put real money into it.
Because you knew I was right.
You knew I was right.
I was just being cautious.
You know your head bobbles up and down when you run.
Like actual running?
Wait, something seems different.
This?
No, that's way too many.
Plugs, right?
I think that's way too many.
Oh, there's way too many.
There's six of everything.
There's six of everything suddenly.
Oh my god, we returned to port.
Oh my god, you're right.
There's six of everything.
I like how you're like, look at the plugs.
I'm like...
Look at everything else.
Very prepared.
You focused on the fucking plugs.
I mean, it's the first thing I saw.
I don't know.
There's so many plugs.
Not the giant red fire hydrant.
There's just so many plugs.
Look, they were covering the wall was the first thing I saw.
Oh, there's a baby.
Oh, there is a baby.
I can't move.
I'm dead.
The baby killed you.
I'm spectating.
The baby killed me.
Babies are dangerous.
Don't look at the baby.
And you were judging me when I killed those two girls.
The baby killed me.
It should have killed you.
I was protecting you, brother.
Brother is about to explode.
There's a TNT.
There he
goes.
Goodbye, brother.
He was a brother to me.
Brother was literally...
You know that meme of the guy sitting and he's like super bright.
That's what he...
Like he's sitting in the little restaurant.
Come inside.
What is wrong with you?
Wait, I was.
I was waiting for you to be inside first.
I was already inside.
No, you were not.
No, no, no.
Check my VOD.
VOD review time.
Time stampers.
I don't think there's anomalies here.
I don't think so either.
I'm pretty sure.
Let's go.
Wait, only four mobs?
I don't think the chat is fucking with us.
No.
509.
Gaslighting.
That was way too detailed.
Because a real chatter would be like...
The head is moved.
You sure?
Yeah.
It's not moving now.
No, like they're in different positions.
Oh.
Are you sure?
Yep.
I'm 100%.
Oh, you're right.
It's moved up closer.
You're right.
I see it.
Easy peasy.
I'm so good at this game.
I'm so good.
I like find everything so quickly before Doki.
I'm sure.
Yeah, yeah.
Like the six plugs that you saw too.
There were actually six plugs?
I don't know why that's what you're so focused on.
That's a lot of...
That was not six plugs.
How do we get out?
Oh god, the collision.
I can't get out.
I'm trying to clip through the wall.
I can't.
Push me.
No, you're not doing anything.
See, what do you mean?
See, this is why we...
Oh, I got out.
I got out.
Come on.
You need...
Oh, it disappeared.
Okay.
Wow, you didn't even try.
See, this is why one of...
Only one of us needed to go inside.
Oh my god.
If it was just one of us...
I still... You still would have needed me.
No, no.
Okay, you can go then this time.
I'm drinking my tea.
Hold on.
Okay, you're drinking your tea.
I see.
I don't think there's anything here.
What are you laughing at?
I'm serious.
There's nothing here.
It's because you walk in for two seconds and you're like, nothing here.
Because I have good memory.
I'm like somebody.
Who has got... Okay.
I actually need chat to...
to keep track of who has gotten the most things in this game.
I swear.
Face in the mirror.
Yeah, don't say me.
Wait, was there a mirror?
There's no mirror in that game.
There's no mirror in there.
I got gas lit.
You know when they're lying?
When they get extra detailed.
Because usually when they think they see an anomaly, they'll be like, mirror.
But then they say face in the mirror.
I got one guide for real.
You got one guide.
Yeah.
5, 12.
Alright, here we go.
I hope it's...
Guys, there's no way Doki would have gotten through this game without me.
I was...
I was so good at exit 8.
Okay.
That's not exit 8.
This is literally exit 8 but multiplayer.
So I did that solo.
It's like a different game.
This is literally exit...
Oh, anomaly.
See, I found it before you.
Wow.
Look at that.
I didn't even see it.
If I said nothing...
That was actually really good.
I'll give you that one.
You don't have to press the button though.
Which means I found it.
If I press the button, that means I found it.
What are these new rules?
She's definitely in kindergarten when they invent new rules.
Yeah,
you were blocking my view actually.
So I just couldn't see it because your big head was in the way.
You know.
I don't think there's anything here.
See, I don't think so either.
No anomaly.
No anomaly?
You don't believe me?
I'm just checking.
Oh, someone doesn't believe me.
Get in there.
Oh, you press the button?
Okay.
Yeah.
This is your choice for no anomaly.
No anomaly.
Five points.
You said it first.
Remember your rule.
Your fucking rule.
It means that you found the anomaly.
But if there was no anomaly...
I don't think there's anything here.
Do you know why we messed up?
We went to the wrong elevator.
We went to the orange light elevator.
No, we didn't.
No, we went to the other one, right?
That's what I'm telling you.
And the rules are too confusing for this game.
Ha ha ha.
The orange light...
It's too bright.
It needs to be more obvious.
I'm telling you.
How much more obvious do they need to be...
The orange light needs to be very bright.
like so bright.
Ha ha ha.
It needs to be on fire.
Oh, I know this.
They need signs, they need signs where it just has like big, like a 15 font text.
It says you came here.
Impact font.
Anomaly here.
No anomaly here.
Oh, it's the bag heads, it's the bag heads.
Okay.
I found it, I found it, I found it.
The one you fucked up, it was you who fucked up.
Not me.
Oh yeah, someone should stay outside for Johnny, you're right.
Oh yeah, you're right, you're right.
Alright, I'll be outside.
I wanna see Johnny.
Oh, rock, paper, scissors.
Rock, paper, scissors.
I think there's no anomaly here.
But you can check.
Don't, don't go that way, don't go that way.
I was just testing you to see if it's like three in a row.
I can't believe we got...
We were so close.
We were at 514.
It's just this one.
Oh my god.
This is why this game is gonna take us three plus hours.
This is why.
I don't think there's an anomaly.
Johnny, Johnny, yes papa.
Well, you gotta wait for me.
No, I was able to get out.
You can too.
Come on.
How?
Push the boxes.
Go outside and push the boxes inwards.
I pushed them outwards.
You can do it too.
Come on, just use your legs.
What do you mean I'm using...
I'm too tall.
I'm sorry for being six foot seven.
Says on my Tinder profile, six foot seven.
Well, I'm gonna wait in the elevator for your lazy ass.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's gone.
Alright, here I am.
Oh my god.
I'm getting there.
Come on.
Oh my god.
I'm going as fast as my six foot seven legs start taking me.
You have really short legs.
You have the widest torso in history.
Three.
Five.
Oh, fuck.
Eight more to go.
Why is it always on 13 that we mess up?
I know.
I think we get too comfortable.
I mean, 13 is an unlucky number.
Oh, brother.
It's brother.
It's a TNT brother.
Brother.
Go, go, go, go.
Please, brother.
Think of your children.
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
Who wants a quick elevator?
He's a creeper.
Yeah, he's a creeper.
Alright.
Don't call our brother a creep.
What's wrong with you?
Oh my god.
What are you talking about?
He still has children.
That doesn't make him a creep at all.
That makes it...
Oh my god.
Alright.
I don't think there's any anomaly here.
Oh, I don't think so either.
Unless there's a new one.
There's no smileys.
Oh, that's true.
We didn't think of new ones.
Yeah.
Brother space.
I think in general it doesn't.
There's no anomalies.
Yeah, I think we're good.
I need sixes on the...
Wait, wait, wait.
Anomaly.
Oh, anomaly.
You're right.
The six, six, six.
I knew it.
I knew the six would come back.
See?
Guys, remember the competition that Mint proposed where whoever catches the most anomalies wins?
What?
What competition?
I just said who has the most.
Who?
This competition that Mint really wanted to do where she was like, oh, guys, time's up.
Every time, like, whoever picks the anomalies.
Okay.
But I'm still winning.
Doki got, like, three.
In your dreams, I guess.
I like how you, like, don't even walk inside.
No, because we wanted to see Johnny.
Oh, yeah.
Remember?
We're trying to get Johnny.
How could you forget about Johnny?
He's been there.
He's been there for us.
Yes, Papa.
All right.
I don't think there's anomalies.
I don't think so either.
All right.
Here we go.
Finally, the closer one.
Yay!
Every time, I was like, ba-dum.
I feel like we're in there.
Wait.
People are saying, oh, we missed it.
What was there?
What?
Huh?
That was you.
You called it.
No, I didn't!
That was you.
You called it.
You were like, we're stuck in floor 500 forever!
The door was backwards?
Wait.
How...
What do you mean the door was?
How can a door be backwards?
Okay.
This is the normal one, remember?
Oh, yeah.
This is the...
Yeah, that's right.
I always forget it.
We're going to be stuck in floor 500.
I could tell you were hydrating before the cry.
Oh, it's on the wrong hinges.
Oh my god, so that's something else we have to...
We have to keep track of the wrong hinges?
So right now... oh no.
Yeah, right now it's backwards.
Oh, it's backwards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh good, we got it out of the way.
That is such a sneaky one.
That is so...
That should have been a floor 516 one right there.
Not stupid!
People miss that too!
Yeah, everyone has probably missed that in their lives.
Yeah, everybody.
Those who called out have played this game before.
I can tell.
Johnny?
Yes, Papa?
It's all the plugs.
All the plugs?
Oh yeah, it's...
It's all the plugs.
We're stuck in 500 forever.
We'll never get to 666.
He was right!
The dev was right!
We will never get to 666!
We're stuck here forever!
It's Chad's fault.
They didn't warn us soon enough.
They could have yelled at us.
They really could have.
They could have screamed if they knew it instantly.
I was going to say, I was going to say, But it seems so mean!
It seems so...
Come on!
Come on, Min!
Okay, I'm coming!
I'm coming!
Come on, Min!
I thought you were so good at this!
I'm coming!
Oh, look at me.
I actually got out.
So it's clearly was just a skill issue for you.
Oh, yeah.
It's not like I helped you get there.
It's like, how could you push me out?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I helped you get there.
Guys, guys, if you guys see any anomalies, make sure to...
We will totally see, and we won't miss it at all.
Awww.
Yeah.
There's no sixes.
I think there's no anomalies.
Yeah.
Guys, this is your chance right now.
We're saying there's no anomalies.
This is your chance.
I'm gonna look at everything really slowly.
We're gonna look at this really slowly.
No anomalies.
If there was an anomaly, it's not our fault.
We gave you a chance.
No Elf.
Alright, here we go.
Up we go.
Bing!
505!
Johnny?
What if we both have to be inside though?
Nah, I don't think so.
Cause like, what if it's a solo, single player?
A single player, it wouldn't matter.
Yeah, because they would be inside.
No, wait, what?
Oh yeah!
Okay.
Okay, doggie.
Alright, no anomalies.
No, we have to go to the further one.
No!
Maybe it'll give us back to back no anomalies.
She's an actual bird.
What does that say about you, huh?
You've messed up too.
Not as much as you.
At least people can say I'm a bird brain.
What about you then?
I'm dead.
I have like, my brain is ectoplasm.
It's literal mush, okay?
Oh, smileys.
Smileys.
Okay, back to the long one we go.
Back to the long one we go.
Don't worry, I'll speed you up.
I'm gonna speed you up.
Actually, you're really not doing anything.
It's like I'm getting a massage.
I'm a chiropractor, not licensed.
Alright.
Next one.
Guys, we're so close to 513 again.
Are we?
We're gonna make it.
Are we that close?
We're... I don't know.
Oh, it's the heads.
It's the heads.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the bags.
At least the shoes running is kind of ASMR.
Yeah, it is.
You know, when it says hospital 666, I honestly thought the 6 was a joke.
Wait, so do we get to like...
What happens?
Do we get to just floor 6?
Or do we do this?
No, it's 666, so it could be like 613.
Like 615.
And then it's all the way to 666 at the end.
Okay.
Great.
Alright.
Johnny.
No Johnny.
Oh, it's the 666.
Okay.
Back to the long hallway we go.
You didn't even go into the room.
I wanna see the Johnny.
Yeah, but what if you have to come inside?
Well, if we have to go inside, I would've got inside to see if we triggered the Johnny.
The Johnny.
That Johnny, that silly guy.
He's so silly.
I wanna see him too, though.
Alright, I'll go inside.
We'll do Russian roulette again.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, one of us has to get the baby and the other one gets Johnny.
Oh, it pushed me inside!
It pushed you inside!
It forced me in!
We get the POV of Johnny again!
Front row seats!
I'm gonna get really close to him.
Yeah, Johnny, we wanna see you.
Woah!
We wanna see your face.
There's Johnny!
There he is!
Sounds like Freddy Fazbear's laugh.
There's Johnny!
Oh my god, someone fucked a stupid meme and said, I see an anomaly!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I never would've got...
Oh, brothers on fire, brothers on fire, brothers on fire.
Why is it always the long one with brothers on fire?
I don't know.
This game is breaking us.
We didn't think, we didn't realize when they said 666 it was literally 666.
666 hours.
You remember when we said 24 hour stream?
We were not joking.
I guess not.
We meant it.
Oh, it's the baby, it's the baby, it's the baby, it's the baby, it's the baby.
Don't go the wrong way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, push me faster.
Baby, baby, baby.
I think we didn't look at the baby, so the baby's not coming.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's stupid baby.
Keep going, you stupid baby.
That's why you're a baby.
You should've died.
You should've died by the baby this time.
Why was I supposed to die by the baby?
Because I died from the baby last time.
Yeah, but you're stupid.
Yeah, because totally I knew that looking at a baby would kill me.
I told you I'm not ready to be a mother!
Well, I saw that Tokyo jungle play through.
You were so ready to be a mother.
You should play that game.
You should build...
You taught me that I killed like your little birdies.
Or is there an anomaly?
Is there an anomaly?
Why are you just standing back there?
Because there was no anomaly.
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
I almost did it.
What are you doing?
There was no Akasupa, so she couldn't tell, guys.
I know.
You guys...
Guys, I was the Akasupa, but I did it for free.
The way you were standing in the hall was so menacing.
What haven't we gotten?
I was like, what is she doing?
No way.
There has to be an anomaly in here.
There's no anomaly.
No.
Guys, we're waiting.
We're waiting for the Akasupa right now.
Wait.
There's something on the floor.
Is that... Oh, it's been like that.
Yeah, it's a face on the floor.
It is.
Oh, shit.
It's Salad Fingers.
We got something new.
We went past Fort 513.
We went past it.
Yay!
New record!
Salad Fingers.
God.
First Doctor Horrible.
What does it say about you?
You recognize these references.
You recognize the references, too.
There hasn't been anything with Brother yet.
I mean, there was one where he grew taller, right?
Oh, no, no.
He exploded.
Just kidding.
Yeah, he exploded.
Yeah.
Why did the Brother explode?
Why did he explode?
Not just once, but three times.
I don't think there's actually one in here.
I don't think so either.
I don't see anything.
There's no faces on the floor.
And someone gave me a blue Super Chat and was like, Akasupa.
Wait, does that mean there's anomaly or there's no anomaly?
Does blue mean safe?
Alright, here we go.
Swipe or no swiping?
Here we go.
Alright.
This is the right.
This is the correct elevator.
Because there's no anomalies.
There's no anomalies.
Why are you having me press it?
You made up the rule.
You are the one that made up the rule.
5-15.
5-15, you guys.
Has there been one that we haven't done yet?
That we haven't saw?
I think we haven't...
Oh, this one.
It's this one.
Yeah.
Dang.
It's the blue screen.
This was the first one we got, I think.
So it was long time ago.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and then it like threw us off.
Because we fire who was real.
5-16.
And I think we haven't gotten the one with the...
Lots of plugs, right?
No, we did.
You're the one that called it out.
Wasn't that on the previous run, though?
Oh, you're right.
Wait, you're right.
Oh, you're right, yeah.
Or did we?
I can't remember.
Everything's blending together, you guys.
All these floors.
We went through so many floors.
No.
I don't know, actually.
Brother?
I don't know.
Brother, help.
4-5.
Brother, we don't know.
I think there's nothing here.
Are you sure?
Oh, you're trusting me, now?
No, I mean, I'm not trusting you.
Brother.
That's true.
No, it ain't me.
Guys, I don't know.
If we fuck up, we go back to zero.
All the way to zero.
If we go...
Guys, you don't want to go back to zero, guys.
Okay, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Here we go.
Everybody go, everybody go.
Here we go!
Oh, you press it.
Here we go.
Why am I pressing it?
Because I pressed it last time!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Come on.
SCP!
You.
No.
Chat.
Did we miss?
Why did we miss?
There was no anomalies.
Did we go to the wrong elevator?
No.
No, we didn't.
No, no, we didn't.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
This is the first level.
No.
Oh, wait.
Someone said review.
We can go review.
We can go review it.
What did we do?
Okay, now we have to review.
No way.
No anomalies.
It wasn't the door.
We got that one.
It was like the first one we got.
Yeah.
Nobody super chatted us.
No smileys.
No one else noticed.
Nobody noticed.
Anything in the trash?
245.
There's...
Is it like a time thing?
Like with the head, you know?
Like we weren't looking in the right direction.
Someone said...
Under the shelf?
Is it this box?
Yeah.
That thing looks weird.
Oh my god.
What?
Look up.
Up?
Look up?
Here?
Look up.
No.
Are you kidding me?
Do you see it?
Is it the 666666?
Look up at the box too.
Look up.
It's the...
This box right here.
They said look up.
There's 6666 labels.
Oh my god.
Here too.
Chat didn't know either.
There was no super chat.
You can't blame it on us.
Apparently there's like...
Oh, all the bottles say 6662.
Oh, they used to say ethanol.
I thought there would only be one 666 because it's the trash cans.
They always...
They baited us.
They always did one and now it's like several?
Now it's two?
This is messed up.
It's not our fault, guys.
It's never the streamer's fault.
One chat member got the labels right.
No, this is so messed up.
One guy in the correct direction.
The one guy was actually correct.
What is this?
Oh my god.
And on the final thing.
On the final one.
That was so cheesy.
That was so cheap.
Oh my god.
So cheap.
We were so happy getting to the sixth...
Bro, we're stuck at 500 forever.
It's okay.
We can speedrun.
We know everything now.
We know them all.
Speedrun.
What is it?
666.
On the...
Wrong elevator.
I saw you.
I saw you running over there.
I saw it.
Alright.
Okay.
We got this.
Wait.
What 666 was it?
Was it on the trash can or the labels?
It was on the trash can.
Okay, okay, I'm keeping track so we can, like, if we get all the anomalies left, then we can just press...
Oh, okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, not us being, like, so excited for some of these.
We're gonna have to get the box one all over again, too.
Oh, no.
Alright, I know how to do this faster.
How?
One person goes?
Yeah.
Okay, okay, there I go.
There I go.
It's gonna force you in here once there's Johnny.
It's the bags.
It's a bag?
See?
Look at how fast it is.
So I can just press the button when you're...
Once I'm here?
What if it's nothing?
What if you have to go all the way back?
I'm gonna lie to you at some point.
I'm gonna tell you that it's...
We all wanna leave the hospital!
If you lie!
It affects you, too!
Here we go.
It's the boxes.
I'm coming out.
No, really?
I'm leaving.
I'm getting out of here.
Really?
I'm coming out.
The boxes?
Wait, I thought you were an expert on this.
What happened?
I'm coming out.
Yeah?
Any second now?
I'm coming out.
Do you see the boxes, like, getting pushed from the...
The boxes are gonna disappear soon.
I'm coming out.
You see, I'm kicking them one by one.
Oh, there you are.
It disappeared, didn't it?
No, it didn't.
You didn't do it yourself.
No, I punched my way out.
You did not do it yourself.
You didn't do it yourself.
Oh, my God.
Here we go.
I'm on my way because...
You got this.
Doki's too much of a baby.
I am not a baby.
I am trying to be efficient here.
I'm not a baby.
I think... Wait, hold on.
Let me check the labels.
Okay.
Smiley's.
Smiley's on the light switch?
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
We fucked up.
Four or five hundred like four times, right?
No, it was like three.
It was like three.
Oh, now you can count.
I think this is our third run.
Now you can count.
Oh, no.
Actually, you don't.
This is our fourth run.
This is actually our fourth run.
It is?
For real?
No way.
Yeah.
I'm with you this time because I think it's no anomaly time.
I think you're right.
I'm double checking everything.
Okay.
You're right.
And you see, I'm so good at gambling.
Probability wise, I was right.
This game.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It's so intense now.
Oh, God.
It's so intense.
Oh, brother is exploding.
Brother is exploding.
Oh, this time it's a close one.
All right.
Exploding brother.
Goodbye, brother.
We are missing the label six.
The label, the baby, the six plugs and the body heads.
Wait, the labels, the baby.
The floor.
Oh, the face.
Face on the ground, salad fingers.
No label.
See, I'm helping now.
Yeah, because we're close.
Now we have to go all the way to the other one.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think we're good.
All the way down.
The hinges.
Yep, that's correct.
Okay.
Oh, that one.
Yeah.
I'm used to checking it on the way to running there.
Yeah, we got Johnny.
Johnny.
Don't forget the floor.
We're good.
Unless I think it like slowly starts to appear, though.
So we might have to, like, wait a second.
Which one?
The floor?
Yeah.
Like, it's like the fade in, like the QR code.
Oh, the QR code.
Yeah.
I'm checking all.
Labels.
Nothing on the floor.
The labels are disinfected.
Yeah.
Do we get the heads at the trash can yet?
Yeah, we already got that one.
Okay.
So we don't care about that.
So I think we're good.
No anomalies.
I think we're good.
Yeah.
No anomalies.
Check the door.
The door is good.
Okay.
We're good.
We're getting better.
It only took us four tries, but we're getting better now.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Bing.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Baby.
All right.
We got baby out of the way.
We're still missing, Johnny, floor, labels.
Johnny floor, iB basket.
We got the trash bag.
Okay.
What was trash back?
The trash.
Yeah.
The trash bag that goes.
Baby, baby, baby, baby, baby...
Angelina not finding the trash bag Oh, Joanie.
It's Joanie.
Okay, it's Joanie.
Holy shit.
I want him to look at me this time.
His eyes kind of look to the right.
You're right.
What's wrong with us anymore?
We need to get to floor 666, you guys!
Please help us!
Help us!
Oh, the door hinges?
We also gotta worry about the door hinges.
666 labels!
Alright, nice!
Alright.
You sound like you're crying.
I think the door hinges are gonna be like the last one, man.
There's nothing on the floor.
Wait, what are we missing?
Oh, the floor?
We're missing the floor.
We're missing the...
Door hinge.
The door hinge.
I think there's nothing.
And also the one of all the, like, the extra plugs.
The six plugs, yeah.
There's nothing, so I think we're good.
I think we're good.
We're back to there.
We're back to there!
We still have a whole other floor!
We still have three more!
Why did you suggest this?
I did.
Why did you agree to this?
Fourteen!
Uh, no, it's not the door hinge.
It should be... last three, right?
I think so.
Last three, so it's all anomalies.
No, this one... unless it's the floor.
It's the floor.
It's all three, so it's all how much you want to bet.
Do you really want to do this?
Do you... do you really want to do this?
It's all... it's literally all anomalies!
You know I'm right!
Okay, okay.
We'll do it.
You know I'm right.
Okay, what are we missing?
We're missing the door hinge.
Yeah.
Which we can see from here.
And we're missing the six.
Yeah.
Which we can see from here.
It's the six plugs.
How much do you want to bet?
Okay, do it.
It's the six plugs.
Yeah, do it.
Do it.
Alright, I'm going to do it.
It's the six plugs.
Alright, the moment of truth.
Do it.
And it's the door hinge.
I can see it.
Yeah, I can see it from here.
Oh my gosh.
I told you!
Okay, that pause though...
I literally held my breath.
I couldn't...
Me too.
I was like...
Oh my gosh, it's the back room.
Are we in the back room?
We're in the back room.
I'm in the back room.
Is it me?
It's me.
I'm literally the sacrifice man.
You got to do this.
I'm trying to find it.
It's chasing me.
I don't know what to do.
Oh my gosh.
It's right there.
It's after me.
Oh my gosh.
No, wait.
It's to the left of the door.
No, I can't get in.
I can't get in.
That's the door.
No!
He has to break it.
He has to break it first.
What is this bullshit?
How do we lead him to that?
Oh my gosh.
Here, you can clutch this.
How do I do it?
Oh my gosh.
You're gaming.
Game of the year.
Why do I always survive?
Did he just sigh?
Did he just go...
Oh my gosh.
600.
600, baby.
We're almost there.
Oh, brother.
Brother.
Okay.
It's the operation room.
Wow.
There's a lot going on in here.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
There's a lot going on in here.
There's another X-ray over here that we can't go in.
Okay.
There's X-rays.
There's a...
There's a calendar here.
May, June, we care about your health.
Okay.
Nice.
I think I absorbed everything in.
Okay.
There's a computer.
The screen is off.
Final stretch, baby.
Okay.
Let's just do it.
The final stretch.
We'll learn as we go.
That's how we did it in floor 500, baby.
Why can't this one be in the middle of the room?
I don't know.
All right.
Here we go.
Brother.
All the screens are off.
Nothing.
No sixes anywhere.
I think it's no anomaly.
Oh my God.
Why am I glitching so bad?
I don't see any anomalies anywhere.
Oh yeah.
Me too.
Oh, whoa.
Is that a glitch?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Or is that an anomaly?
I think... Is that an anomaly?
I think... Oh, oh.
I'm glitching so much even now.
Whoa.
Yeah, I think...
I think that's an anomaly.
Is that an anomaly?
Oh my God.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That has to be an anomaly.
There's no way.
There's no way, right?
There's no...
Well, fine.
I mean, we're in 601.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That has to be an anomaly.
That has to be.
Yay.
That was cool.
I like that one.
That was a cool anomaly.
Yeah.
I thought we were lagging.
Me too.
Whoa.
Brother scares me every time, man.
That was such a creative anomaly, though.
Yeah.
That one's fun.
Because you can't tell if it's kusoge or not.
Yeah.
It's like you are the game itself.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
I'm looking up.
Disease history.
Nothing.
Nothing?
I don't see anything.
I don't see anything either.
I think we're actually good this time.
Here we go.
Anomaly.
Door on the wrong side.
No.
Oh.
The plant.
Don't fuck with us like that.
I'm checking now, though.
I'm checking.
All right.
603.
And the labels.
Yeah.
We have to check the labels, too, just in case.
Just to see if there's any sixes.
Bing.
603.
603, baby.
Let's go.
I think Brother's going to be standing at one point.
He's going to freak us out.
Or he's going to change his face.
Okay.
He's fine right now.
Nothing on the monitors.
Nothing.
Nothing on the side.
Nothing in the operating.
No 666 anywhere.
I'm checking.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
It's the same date.
History.
There's no way that there's nothing here.
I don't know.
We could get two in a row.
No anomalies.
I guess so.
That's the secret one.
No anomalies for twice.
I don't think so.
All right.
Wait.
Did they not hear that?
Hear what?
Did you hear something?
They're fucking with you.
There's no way.
What was that noise?
Wait, what do you mean?
I don't hear anything.
MBM, really?
Oh, that's you?
That's me.
Is that hole on the bed?
What?
There's always been a hole here.
What hole?
There's always been a hole there.
This hole?
The oper...
Was that a girl?
What?
I'm scared now.
That's always been a hole.
Oh, there's a hole.
There's a hole in this hole here, yeah.
It's always been there.
What do you mean?
Hold on.
Shh.
Wow.
Very realistic.
Look, we've been playing for almost four hours.
I can't dedicate a voice for it.
Let's just go.
Okay.
Anyway.
All right.
Up we go.
I mean, we're at 603.
There's no way.
At best, we retry three floors.
Okay.
We are so nervous here...
It's better than not.
It's bigger than...
Okay.
Let's see if there's a hole in the bed.
Let's see.
There was no hole in the bed.
There's no hole on the bed.
We were like, there's always been a hole.
We were thinking of like, the fucking chiropractor.
I was like, are you massaging?
I figured out this is an operating room.
I thought it was there to keep your head comfy.
Me too.
Okay, well now we know.
Whoa, what's the game?
Oh, whoa, it's us.
Oh, it's you.
It's my POV.
It's your POV.
Alright, now we know.
Okay.
Guys, at least it was like three floors.
Yeah, it's fine.
Now we know.
And then we call chat crazy.
We're like, guys, there's always been a hole.
You're crazy.
I'm the protagonist.
They were like, literally, they were like, there's a hole there.
We're like, yeah, they're always asking.
We said it so confidently.
I know.
We were so like, yeah, duh.
Of course there's a hole.
Oh my gosh.
All operating tables have a hole in it.
Yeah.
May, June, July.
History, mm.
I don't think I see anything here.
Mystery, mm, is there.
Brother.
There's no 666.
We've been doing this for a while now, brother.
Brother, please.
Brother.
Let us free.
Brother, uh.
Come on.
Okay.
But like, also chat was gaslighting us while telling us there's a hole.
Yeah, they were saying, exactly.
Did you hear that?
Of course we're gonna think that.
We think that everything is wrong.
No, we didn't hear anything.
Um.
There's no sixes.
Oh, look.
Is there anything on the other side?
No.
You care about your health.
May, June, July.
Um.
The labels are normal.
Labels are normal.
The x-rays are normal.
Uh.
There's no hole on the wall this time.
I thought I heard like a beeping, but it might have been like just ambience.
Yeah.
I think it's ambience.
I didn't hear a beeping.
Okay.
We go to the other side.
All right.
No, it's not your fault, chat.
The hole made a noise.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
It wasn't your chat that pointed it out.
Or anything, you know.
And you chose to ignore it.
You chose to ignore it.
All your chat said was you hear the noise.
My chat actually called the hole in the bed.
They probably heard me like humming and were just like, uh-oh.
That wasn't normal.
Obvious.
It wasn't.
They were just trying to be helpful.
They were just trying to...
I don't...
What?
There's nothing.
I don't see anything.
I can't...
Uh.
No.
Vitamin complex.
Yeah.
There's no 666.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
I'm looking to see if any heads pop up.
Door hinges are good.
Um.
Wait.
See if there's lag.
Oh, yeah.
No.
No lag.
So, here?
Is it none?
The floor.
What about the floor?
No gas light.
There's no gas light.
Oh, my God.
The wires say 666.
666.
I saw it before you.
No.
I saw it.
I trust my chat.
I saw it in my chat.
That is...
I noticed that they were in perfect circles.
But I thought he just copied and pasted them.
I thought he was being a lazy dev.
After 600 floors?
This is the part where he gets lazy?
Don't worry, Wisps.
I know you guys saw it first.
No.
Don't worry, Dragoons.
I knew you...
No.
You guys are so good.
You guys are the best ever.
I knew you guys were right.
No.
Because I trust my chat.
I know.
Oh, my God.
Hole in the bed.
All right.
We know.
Hole in the bed is gone.
Yeah.
Hole in the bed is gone, everybody.
We got hole in the bed out of the way.
We were so fucking confident.
Oh, God.
We were like scolding our chat.
We were like, what?
There is no...
There is always hole in the bed.
606.
Oh, my God.
That's 10 away.
I mean, wait.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
What?
I was going to say 10 away from 666.
Yeah.
I was going to say that.
Wait.
Look.
Brother.
Brother is being polite.
Brother is...
Oh, my God.
Brother.
Brother?
Where is he?
Brother is talking to someone, I think.
Oh, brother.
Okay.
We're going.
Brother.
Brother has been in this hospital a bit too long.
Brother finally is speaking.
It's okay, brother.
All right.
Up we go.
He looks like really kind of...
He's slaying right now.
He was like flirty with whoever he was talking to.
Bro.
Whoever he was talking to.
He was like, hey.
I know.
I like...
I want that anomaly again if we fuck up.
I can't wait to get flirty brother back.
I miss flirty brother.
There's Raiden in the operating room.
Who the fuck is that?
I don't know.
I triple dog dare you to go see him.
Yeah.
Go up to him.
We got to do this again if we...
No.
Not necessarily.
Wait.
He just...
She's like...
How?
I don't know.
She's like half-clip to the floor.
What is she going to do?
Phase through and kill me?
She might.
I'm leaving.
What happened to moral support?
I never said that.
Oh.
Now you're not going to support me morally.
I've never supported you morally.
All right.
Raiden, turn off the game console.
608!
We're getting there!
We're missing the monitor in the lab.
There's a baby in the...
There's a baby?
There's a child.
Baby, you need help?
He's not moving.
Wait, what?
He's counting, he's counting down.
He's counting down!
93...
92...
Why does he sound like that?
We have like 100 seconds.
We have like 100 seconds!
Why does he sound like that though?
95...
94...
93...
Somebody put baby in the corner.
609, baby!
Well, hopefully there's no baby.
Alright, we got one baby.
Every floor has a baby.
No.
Nothing in the monitor.
Oh, I'm lagging, I'm lagging.
Are you?
I think so.
I'm not.
Oh, maybe my game is...
No, I'm not.
I think it's because I bumped into you, maybe.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm walking back and forth.
Oh, okay, okay.
Never mind.
Um...
Kusoge.
Don't care about your health.
May, June, July.
Disease, history, mmm.
I don't see anything.
I don't see anything either.
Nothing on the labels.
House kids.
All the labels are not 666.
Um...
I think we're fine.
Yay, we're at the closer door!
We're at the closer X-ray!
I'm trusting you, I'm trusting you.
Okay, then you go back into the room, then.
I'm scared.
You go back into the room.
You're going to trust me and you're not confident enough.
I'm scared.
I don't know.
I don't know, I'm nervous.
I feel like usually the things are... I don't know.
Okay, people are like, blood?
But they're not even confident about it.
They're saying like, is that blood by the brother?
But I don't see anything at all.
There's blood by the brother?
I don't think so.
I think they're...
They're being way too specific.
Yeah, there's blood.
What?
What are you talking about?
Where?
Behind the brother?
There's no blood anywhere.
Are we really on the cabinet door?
What?
Okay, I'm pretty sure.
I'm so confused.
I am confused too.
I'm trying to see.
I'm trying to look around to see if we missed anything.
Blood inside you.
That's a medic bag.
I'm dead.
Okay.
Oh, a nectoplasm.
Yeah.
Get it right.
Okay, hopefully.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I mean, if we get this right, it's 610.
Let me just rip off the band-aid, man.
Just rip off the band-aid.
Come on.
Oh my god.
What just happened?
Oh.
Hello, where are you?
Where are you?
I'm in exit 8!
No way.
You're in exit 8?
Yes, I'm in exit 8!
You got teleported?
I want to get teleported.
I'm in exit 8 too.
Oh, hey.
No way.
Keep left?
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Aren't we supposed to go backward if it's a...
Yeah, we go back.
We go backwards.
It's an anomaly.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's actually exit 8.
Oh my god.
We got easy guide to exit 8.
Oh, we're back.
Wait, we're back?
Okay.
I think that's an anomaly, guys.
I don't know about that one.
Is it the same dev?
Or no?
No, it's a different dev.
It's a parody.
That's so funny.
We got easy guide to exit 8.
Some of these anomalies are pretty good, actually.
Yeah, they're actually pretty funny.
Oh, wait.
I think I'm lagging.
Is this a lag?
I think this is lag.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait.
Is it?
Unless we just pushed each other weird.
Okay.
I'm going inside.
Oh, wait.
I'm lagging.
Wait.
No, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It is.
That's...
Oh, whoa, whoa.
I'm trying to get out.
Let me out.
I see it pushing me so hard.
Oh, yes.
Oh, I still can't believe I teleported to exit 8.
I know.
That was crazy.
That was a good one.
You didn't even want to join me.
I went in.
Okay.
Is there any 666?
I'm not paranoid for any 666 references.
I know, right?
Oh, my God.
Ever since room 515.
I'll never forget 515.
I'll never forgive.
Never forget.
915, 516.
I'll never forget 516.
This one looks good, I think.
Yeah, I think so, too.
Anything behind the brother?
Just for chat's sake?
Where's the blood?
Okay.
All right.
Seems fine.
I think we're good.
Yeah.
All right.
Heading to the other side.
No, we have to head to the other side.
Doki checked the labels, right?
You checked the labels?
Sure.
Time to look at the numbers.
Okay.
Time to look at the...
All right.
This is your fault.
Oh, my goodness!
You said you checked.
We're reviewing.
Oh, my God.
We're not getting stucked.
We're not getting stuck here.
What was it?
Labels.
No, they're fine.
Is it the x-rays?
Were they suppose to be closer to the metacars or not?
The calendar?
We care about your health.
I think that's what it says.
Is the x-ray supposed to be closer together?
What was it?
There's nothing up top.
Wait, actually?
The plugs?
Yeah.
Wait, what do you mean the plugs?
It's the walls.
Oh my god!
I just saw them!
That is so cheeky!
Oh my god.
It doesn't appear until...
They're making it really obvious.
I can't believe we didn't see that.
Oh my god.
It's because they don't appear soon enough.
They don't appear soon enough, man.
Speedrunner's bane.
Zero.
This is zero.
Yeah, just keep going, keep going.
Give it up for the four hours!
We're gonna make it!
God, you're actually right.
It's almost been four hours of this game!
Give it up for hour number four!
Okay, we got majority anomalies this time.
Yeah, it's true, it's true.
But we get to see Flirty Guy again.
Oh yeah, we got to see Flirty Boy again!
Flirty Brother again!
Flirty Brother.
I miss Flirty Brother.
Yeah.
Wait, it's the same.
Maybe it's a win.
It's the walls, it's the walls.
Wait, is it the walls?
Are you sure?
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah, yeah, it's the walls.
Good, good, good.
We got it out of the way.
Oh my god.
I got it out of the way.
I was like, are my eyes deceiving me because we went through that?
Oh my god.
In another world, it would have been like five floors left in another world.
Let's go.
This might be the first one last time too, right?
Anomaly, Anomaly, come over here.
Oh, I see it.
I saw it.
Then monitor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, we get to do Exodate again!
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
That was fun.
Yeah.
I wonder if it would be the same one.
The same Anomaly with the poster.
Oh, maybe.
Probably, right?
I think it's probably.
Yeah, probably.
Unless they coded like several.
The one I don't want...
I don't like the lagging one.
It hurts my brain.
Oh, the lagging one was freaky.
There's no 666.
Because we're missing some Anomaly's that we haven't got.
Yeah, there's a few.
So like I'm worried.
But I think this one's okay.
I don't think so.
Yeah, I think this one's okay.
I think we're good.
Yeah.
To the next floor!
Next floor!
I won.
Oh, Discord lag.
I didn't realize this was a competition, but okay.
You held your note for a long time.
I assumed that we were trying to beat you.
I mean, that's what you would assume, isn't it?
No 666 on the floor, no baby.
No baby and nothing seems odd.
No hole in the bed.
Yeah, I think we're fine.
I think we're good.
Yeah, we're good.
Are we?
Yeah!
Ceiling?
What's wrong with the ceiling?
I'm checking the ceiling.
They always say ceiling.
I know, they really do.
They always do.
They never stop with the ceiling.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, here we go.
We're so close.
6-0-5!
Listen, more than 10 left.
11 left.
Go, go, go.
Go, brother.
It's fine.
Nothing.
No cables.
Everything's fine.
No sixes.
Oh, care about your health.
Labels are fine.
May, June, July.
No history.
Ceiling, nothing.
It says exit here.
I think we're good.
There's no hole in the wall.
Let's go.
Really?
Two in a row?
Two in a row.
The game's being nice to us.
Let's go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
I'm worried about the one thing.
That's like...
Because we haven't seen three anomalies.
Yeah, I know.
So it's like...
We don't know what to expect.
What to expect.
Come on.
6-0-6!
Yes!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
It's...
Is that Steve Brother?
Wait, no.
Never mind.
No.
Oh, it's the monitor.
It's the monitor.
Oh, the monitor.
You're right.
Again?
Didn't we get the monitor before?
There's two different ones, right?
There was?
I think so.
Where did we go?
I thought we already did the brother.
I'm not the brother.
The monitor?
The monitor.
Yeah.
I thought we already did the monitor already.
It's your smoker baby.
I think the next one will be the baby.
Baby in the corner!
Baby, baby, baby.
Oh, apparently there is two.
Nice.
Okay.
Yeah.
Because I was like, I don't remember seeing two.
Oh, no baby in the corner.
It's the cable.
Oh, 6-6-6.
6-6-6.
Why can't it be the closer elevator?
God damn it.
Give us a closer one.
Wow.
Someone's so slow today.
No.
I have a bug that's flying in my face.
Oh, no.
Does a bug know about 6-6-6?
I killed it.
Oh.
Whoa.
With your hand?
Yeah.
I thought it was a ghost.
I killed it just now.
Is it a ghost bug?
It is now.
Nothing here.
Oh, it's a lady.
It's Raiden.
Raiden.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Turn off the game console.
Oh, my God.
We're doing it.
We're speed running.
We're so good now.
Woo.
609.
It's okay.
Seven more.
Oh, my God.
Punching you so we get there faster.
Zesty brothers.
Zesty brother.
Nope.
Baby.
Hole in the bed.
Ghost.
We punch each other to get us.
Help.
We need to get to 666.
We were like, okay, we found it.
Go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Come on.
There we go.
I wonder if you failed the exit eight, do I lose?
I don't know.
Like before, right?
Yeah.
Because we got it right before.
We still have the lag.
Nope.
Oh, baby.
Again.
The camera.
What the fuck?
Oh, I saw it.
I saw it.
Oh.
Oh, that's weird.
Oh, my God.
That's so weird.
That's like the camera, the dead POV.
Yeah.
That's kind of fun.
That's fun.
All right.
Someone needs to work out more there.
I was looking at it.
Do you not want to leave the hospital?
I'm enjoying my time.
It's literally a camera.
I'm enjoying my camera.
Zesty Brothers.
Baby in the corner.
Maybe in the corner.
Nope.
Baby in the corner.
Maybe in the corner.
We just have Brother and Exodate.
That's all the ones we've seen.
Right?
Yeah.
.
Are you...
I was like, where did you go?
Oh.
What happens when he counts to zero?
That's what I'm wondering.
I'm really curious.
You want me in the elevator?
You want me in the elevator, Tokyo?
You want me...
No, no, go closer to that room!
Go closer!
What did...
What did he say?
Is he not...
He's not counting anymore.
Can you stop clowning?
I don't think he expects us to save you.
I don't think he does.
He got lazy!
I'm telling you!
Lazy Dev!
He doesn't even fucking count all the way to the end!
You don't get count all the way to the end!
Start from ten!
I know, right?
The Dev got ten.
I'm tired.
He was like, well, you're supposed to be gone.
Oh, oh, oh.
Exit A?
Yeah, exit A, exit A.
Okay, I'm gonna see if you...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What?
I wanna see you pop into existence.
Oh, okay, okay, I can do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, it's an anomaly!
I gotta go back!
Is it the same one?
Yeah, it's the same one.
Oh, okay.
Let's see what you look like when you pop back in.
Here I go.
Where are you?
I'm coming back.
Oh, I'm here.
It's this way.
Oh, it's this way.
He's popped inside.
Okay, up we go.
Three more!
Who are we missing?
Oh, we're missing Zesty Brother, and then I think two others, right?
Yeah, two others we haven't seen before.
Oh, and Lag.
I don't think we've gotten the Lag one yet.
Oh, we didn't ever get the Lag one.
Okay, so then what is... we have one anomaly that we haven't got before.
Okay, okay, okay, we got this, we got this.
Oh, what is this?
Is it the Lag?
No, no, no, look, look, look.
It's like unfinished textures.
No textures.
Oh, everything has no textures!
Oh my god!
Oh, so everything has to be an anomaly now.
Everything is a PNG.
No, no, no.
Okay, 14.
Oh wait, no, we're missing one.
No, I think it's better to... yeah.
We're missing one because we have...
We have to check.
We have one too?
Yeah, yeah, we have to check.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, it's fine.
Lazy Dev.
My immersion.
This isn't a video game.
This is real life.
I'm stuck in the game.
Please help.
We're stuck in a hospital.
Zesty Brother!
He's having a good time.
Okay, nice.
Okay, Lag and then Unknown.
Yes.
All right, up we go.
We didn't take the wrong elevator too.
We did it.
Okay, come on, come on.
We didn't take the wrong elevator.
We're good.
We got this.
This is the... how... how we can't fuck it up now?
It's gotta be the lag, right?
Yeah, it has to be the lag.
Or something else.
Or no anomaly.
Um, run around to see if we lag at all or...
No lag?
Um...
Oh, wait.
I don't like this because we don't...
We don't know.
Wait.
Wait, I don't like this because it's not lag.
I don't either.
It's too much of a mystery.
This is a mystery.
Labels.
The labels are fine.
I'm looking at the calendar.
Yeah.
Medical center first.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
There's no 666.
Uh, no.
Oh, no.
Nothing with the table, the bed.
History.
Disease, history.
Hmm.
The x-rays.
There's no sixes.
Nothing with the x-rays.
They all look the same.
The walls aren't smiling this time.
No.
I don't like this myth.
I don't either.
I don't like this.
Yeah, we got the wall.
The wall was the first one we got.
Yeah.
The x-rays are okay.
The ceiling.
Nothing on the ceiling.
I think.
Aww.
I don't know, man.
Does anyone know me?
I don't know.
I don't know about it.
I think we're good.
Okay.
I'll press the button.
I'll take the...
Oh, okay.
You take the blade.
We pressed it.
Wait, what?
I've heard...
We don't have to do this!
I lagged.
I'm lagging in the elevator.
This is it!
Good luck, Mint.
We're at the... we're at the floor.
What floor are we at?
666!
We're here.
Here we go.
Just run for it.
Wait, the elevator's not open though.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Oh, I think something is gonna come from that elevator.
Wait, no, but then like...
I think we need to turn around.
I think we need to...
What the hell?
Was that a PNG?
Yeah, that was a PNG.
I think we just gotta...
This way.
Oh, the sheet ghost!
The sheet ghost!
It's your cousin!
It's my cousin!
Just run!
Oh, it's the body bag!
It's the body bag!
It's just a normal guy.
It's Anita!
It's a normal guy!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
No!
How did you die?
I don't know!
I think we have to like...
As soon as it starts ringing, we gotta... we gotta turn around.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, that means he's faster than us.
That's messed up!
Yeah, it's up there!
Okay.
There we go.
Turn around, turn around.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Turn around, turn around.
We wasted too much time.
Oh, yeah.
Go, go, go, go!
Let's go, don't stop!
Just don't stop!
Don't look back!
I'll punch you through the tree!
I'll punch you!
I'll punch you if you get too close!
Okay, okay.
Punch me!
I'll punch you if you get too close!
Normal guy!
You're doing normal things!
Oh my god.
Are you punching me?
I'm punching you!
It's not working!
I'm doing my best!
Oh, it worked!
It worked!
I'm doing my best!
Don't die!
Don't die, doggy!
I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna do it!
I'm sacrificing my life!
I did everything!
Fuck off!
Oh my god.
I'm punching!
Oh my god, it's a doggy!
Oh my god, he was right there.
He was right there.
Oh my god.
He was right behind us.
Complete normal mode is what it said.
Oh my god, it was a doctor!
He wanted to get paid!
I like how this entire Critics is this one guy.
He's this one guy.
Marketing manager.
VTuber.
Sales manager.
Developer.
YouTube anomaly acting.
School 666!
School 666?
Oh, I know what we're playing next.
Oh my god.
Wait, are we going to classroom 666?
How are we gonna do it?
Is it gonna be floors?
Wasn't there an easy mode to this?
Like...
Yeah, the easy mode is that there's a routine.
So like...
Oh.
Wait.
What?
Wait, we're still here.
It said...
I got it.
There was an achievement too that was just like you escaped the hospital, but have you really?
Is this hard mode?
There's more?
Oh my god.
The blood is like...
Yeah, but like...
But like...
Blood texture.
What is the hard...
What?
What's the difference?
I don't know.
What's the difference, Mint?
Is this...
Just keep going.
Just go to the next...
Go to the elevator.
I thought...
It says exit.
I thought it was over.
It's fine.
Just keep going up.
I thought...
But it's back to zero.
No, no.
It's fine.
It's back to zero.
We're fine.
We're okay.
It's back to zero.
It's all good.
Oh no.
I don't understand.
What would be different?
I think the game is over.
I think the game is over too.
I think...
I think there's a return to menu button that we are allowed to play.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I...
Yeah, I see it too.
I see it.
You see that menu?
Oh my god.
It just showed up.
I got it.
I got into the elevator and the return to menu button showed up.
Oh my god.
Me too.
Yeah.
It just happened.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my...
Wait.
I'm in the menu.
Oh, you left?
Oh my...
No.
It showed up.
She's gone, you guys.
She's gone.
I'm going to the next floor.
You're going to the next floor.
Are you actually?
There's like a giant handprint.
What are these?
Giant...
Oh.
What are you...
Is that you?
That's me.
That's the anomaly.
How did you do that?
Wait.
You were over there.
They're both orange.
They're both orange light.
Which is the OG.
No, they're not.
That one's only one that's orange.
That one's orange for me.
I think you fucked up.
They're both orange.
I think you messed up.
I think I fucked up the light.
Yeah.
I think you messed it up.
Everything is like light now.
It's so bright.
Is this...
This has to be the hard mode, right?
So let's go to the menu.
I'm going to go to the menu and see if it's unlocked.
It has to be the hard mode.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I'm returning to menu.
But, like, what's the hard mode, though?
Let's see.
New game.
Oh, yeah.
It's hell.
Return to floor 000 if you fail.
Oh.
It's the same.
It's just that you go back to zero.
Okay.
So we finished.
We beat the game.
Wait.
Is this actually...
But is it...
Hold on.
It basically, like, instead of returning back to, like, you know, instead of returning back to, like, floor 100, floor 200, floor 300, it goes back to zero.
Yeah.
But is it also different floors?
It's different floors, too.
I don't think so.
I'm starting a new game.
Are you fucking...
I'm curious.
Go some balls.
Is it bloody?
You have to host the game.
You have to host this.
No.
It's bloody.
So, yeah.
The hard mode is the bloody mode.
Yeah.
Okay.
I would assume it is.
We did it.
We beat the game.
It only took us four hours.
What's the speedrun of this?
Speedrun.com.
Hospita...
It took us less than four hours.
Oh, you're right.
Because we had one hour to set up time.
Yeah.
One hour to set up time.
And also, it's not been four hours yet.
It's been...
Not yet.
It's been one week since we...
Wait.
Oh, my God.
We can be in the...
We can get in.
There's only...
We should submit our runs to speedrun.com.
There's only two participants.
Yeah.
No, we're gonna be at the leaderboards.
We're gonna be at the leaderboards.
First place is the creator.
Stop.
I think that's cheating.
That is actual cheating.
I like how first place is the creator.
How much is time?
What's his time?
30 minutes?
34 minutes?
No.
That's not fair.
It's not even fair.
Oh, my God.
It's not the creator.
It's some other guy.
I messed up.
It's not the creator.
I thought it was the creator, because I was wrong.
I saw Hong Kong, because I know that Dev is from Hong Kong.
But what if it's...
Maybe then it's a friend, and he fed the answers.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
It was one month ago.
We could be the third and fourth place.
If I submit first, I get third place.
Oh, my God.
Doki.
The creator of that background just followed me on Twitter.
The laundry man.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to like the laundry man.
Go get the laundry man.
In fact, I'll follow them back.
You have to use the laundry man now.
You have to.
How did they know?
When will we get meaning that ghost girl at the laundry man role play?
ASMR.
I will get the laundry man.
I'll get the laundry man background, everybody.
Where will we get?
Laundromat ASMR RPGs.
I'm a maid.
I belong in the laundry room.
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm tired.
This was fun.
And it was a team effort with the wisps and the dragoons working together.
The wisp goons.
Team effort.
We all did this together, guys.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, team.
Good job, dragoons.
Give yourself a pat on the back.
Especially the dragoons.
Oh, especially.
The wisps helped, like, crazy, crazy amounts.
Yeah.
Even though, like, Mint didn't believe you sometimes.
Dragoons, like, the hole in the bed.
Oh, yeah.
You know.
But I know Doki, like, kind of doubts you guys all the time.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
No, wait.
I always believed.
I always...
Did you agree?
Good job, everybody.
Good job, guys.
Good job, every wisp.
Good job, every dragoon.
You guys did it.
Remember the time stamp.
Whoever gets the most correct, guys.
Okay.
Whoever gets the most correct, then what is it?
What do we get?
What do we have to do?
We have to...
What's the punishment?
Like...
I don't know.
Okay.
We decide the punishment later.
Oh.
You decide.
You want to decide?
Only if you...
Only if you do it.
Oh.
Are you not confident?
Are you not confident that you're going to win?
No.
I'm pretty confident.
I think I'm good.
You're pretty confident?
Yeah.
Why didn't you decide something right now then?
You're so confident.
You're the one who was just like, we'll decide later.
Yeah.
Because like...
Because we don't know.
We don't know the result.
If you're so confident, then figure out something now.
Loser has to use the other person's gamer sub's code.
Okay.
Deal.
Let me grab...
Let me buy the free pack.
The free sample pack.
Oh.
No.
GG's guys.
GG's everybody.
Are you going to chat with your wisp?
Because I'm just going to head off.
We did a long stream.
I think...
I'm trying just a little bit.
But yeah.
Not very much.
Okay.
Alright.
GG's man.
GG's.
Bye.
Cool.
I just want to...
I just want to chill for a second before we...
Before we...
Before I leave you all.
I just want to chill for just a second.
Just a little bit.
Oh.
I'm missing.
Hold on.
Give me a second.
Let me put on some BGM.
Just for a second.
That was...
Oh my god.
My brain is mush.
Every day.
This week.
Every day my brain has become more mush as I continue onwards.
I think.
Oh.
Gosh.
I don't know what song to put on.
Hold on.
Um.
Whisp goons are the real winners tonight.
I hope you guys enjoyed that.
Happy to report I have zero brain cells after that.
Me too.
I literally feel like my head is just like actually mush.
Oh my god.
That was fun though.
Thank you.
My throat hurts.
Thanks for lining up my week.
Thank you.
Thanks Virgil.
I hope you guys enjoyed that as an end to your week.
Um.
Happy Friday everyone.
Cobalt.
Thanks for the vibe gifted.
Thank you.
That thinking part is the problem.
You should try stopping.
Of course.
Yeah.
Um.
Uh.
The um.
Obvious answer here is never trust.
Doki's game choices.
Uh.
Um.
But yeah.
I'm going to head out.
Um.
I will see you guys later.
Tomorrow.
For Metal Gear.
I will be playing up until um Doki's uh new skin suit reveals.
So you can um look forward to that.
Um.
But.
For now.
I'm gonna head out.
And.
Happy Friday everyone.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Ah.
It's been four hours.
So um.
Yeah.
Got my postcard in the mail today.
Yippee.
Thank you.
Yes.
My gamer code.
My gamer subs code everybody.
Save 10% on.
Actually.
Um.
Before I.
They actually contacted me so long ago.
They were like do you want to become a gamer subs partner.
Uh.
And I was like.
Um.
Let me.
I've never had gamer subs before.
So like let me have it.
Before I.
Try it.
Because.
Um.
I've tried.
What's the word.
Uh.
Skip ads.
Shut up.
It's my first sponsor.
Please.
Let me have my first sponsor.
Um.
I've tried.
Like.
And I mean this.
Legitimately.
I've tried.
Like other.
What's the word.
Other.
Uh.
Those like other.
Like.
Gamer themed.
Powdered drinks.
And the last one I had.
Which.
I never got a sponsorship for.
But I tried it.
Because.
Um.
A friend was sponsored by them.
And I.
Got it.
And like.
It was not.
I didn't like it at all.
It was so grainy.
And so bad.
But this one.
I actually liked.
So I was like.
Oh.
Well.
I don't mind.
Because.
I wanted to try it.
Before I was like.
I'm gonna promote it to you guys.
So.
You know.
I legitimately tried it.
Before I was like.
You know.
Because what if I tried it.
And I was like.
Ew.
This is so bad.
Powdered energy drink stuff.
Is hit or miss.
It can be very miss.
Yeah.
What flavor do you recommend?
Um.
I like mixing the mango.
And the raspberry.
But they are both.
Non-caffeinated.
So.
Mmm.
But um.
They sent me a ton of things.
They were like.
Which ones do you want to try?
So.
I got to try.
I got.
I was like.
Oh.
I want to try mango.
I want to try raspberry.
I want to try the.
Anime thighs.
And.
They sent me a bunch of like.
Their.
Um.
The.
The nutritional bars too.
And some of the ramen.
But I haven't had any of the ramen.
It's all in my.
I keep looking over to the left.
Because it's all sitting there.
In a box.
Um.
But yeah.
But um.
I.
So.
You can guarantee that.
I at least tried it before I'm.
Before I'm selling it to you guys.
And I do like the flavors.
I'm not going to.
I'm not going to try and sell something to you guys.
That.
I think is.
Shitty.
So.
Um.
I'm not going to just try and get my bag.
You know.
So.
Mint seal of approval.
Buy with confidence.
Yeah.
I will turn down something.
If I think.
I don't.
Like it.
Um.
So.
And I mean that.
For like.
I guess.
Any kind of sponsor.
Hmm.
I've already had all of it.
It's good.
Yeah.
I think so too.
I haven't tried.
I'll be honest.
They sent me the chocolate peanut.
Or the chocolate bars.
And the peanut butter bars.
Um.
Oh.
No.
I have had the peanut butter one.
I think.
I think it was kind of sweet.
Consume gamer subs.
Happy you got a sponsor.
Me too.
And.
I have more cool stuff on the way.
As well.
I had a meeting.
With um.
With a company.
Yesterday.
A Japanese company.
That reached out to me.
And um.
At first.
I was like.
Nervous.
Should I.
I was like.
I don't feel confident enough.
In my Japanese.
To.
To contact them.
But.
I hired a translator.
Actually.
And um.
So.
I had the meeting.
Last night.
And uh.
I hired the translator.
To help.
And um.
I asked them.
I was just like.
Have you worked with any.
Western Vtubers before?
And they were like.
No.
You would be the first.
So.
So I'm kind of excited about that.
Actually.
I've been drinking gamer subs.
For like.
Two weeks straight.
My blood is.
Gamer subs.
And now.
You can use my code.
Yippee.
So um.
Yeah.
There's some cool things.
Happening.
So um.
When are they releasing.
Minced thighs.
As a flavor?
If I ever get a flavor.
I already have an idea.
But I'm not going to tell you guys.
Not yet.
I don't know if I'm getting a flavor yet.
So.
Hmm.
Um.
Yeah.
Okay.
But yeah.
So.
I am trying to plan stuff.
I am trying to.
Do stuff.
It's just a little slower.
Because it's so slow.
It's just me.
You're pretty good.
At this whole Vtuber thing.
I'm trying.
It's hard.
But.
You know.
Did you tell the Japanese company.
To use code.
Boomer.
Stop.
Stop trying to guess my.
I think.
Actually.
I don't think any of you.
Would guess my flavor.
That I want.
At least.
I drink multiple bottles.
Of the red raspberry.
Per night.
Every night.
It's a problem.
They actually.
They have like.
New ones.
That are kind of like.
I think.
I don't think.
They.
It says they have no melatonin.
But it's supposed to help you.
It's supposed to help you sleep.
So.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll try it.
Bulba flavor.
Bulberry.
Actually.
That's so cute.
Corn soup.
Energy drink.
That's what the world needs.
A corn soup.
Flavored.
Energy drink.
Mince flavor.
Ecto corn.
Cooler.
Pretend the hammer.
Is a head pat.
Why?
You guys.
Want a head pat.
Emote.
So bad.
I should commission.
Some more emotes.
I'll be honest.
I haven't.
Commissioned any.
But.
Okay.
I'm gonna head out.
Because.
Tomorrow.
Is.
Quite a long day.
As well.
And I have.
I have.
Early.
Stream.
So.
I will see you guys.
Tomorrow.
For.
Metal Gear.
I'm so excited.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
For the long stream.
But.
Today.
Longer stream.
At least.
And I will see you guys.
Tomorrow.
See you guys.
Later.
Have a good night.
And if I don't see you.
This weekend.
Have a great weekend.
And.
Yeah.
Go.